welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happened now is brought to you by
nature box listen the goods the holidays
mean one thing go go go
you got presents to wrap travel to plant
relatives to braise for with all that it
can be hard to find time to eat healthy
let nature box help with the snacks
they're both delicious and better for
you if you're trying to be better the
holidays are a minefield you know that
chocolate cookies candy canes everybody
I just have one piece
it's no fun feeling left out
deliciousness let naturebox help you
with snacks that you love and there's a
seriously delicious and better for you
and right now what I'm gonna do for you
uncle Joey right off the bat see some
people show up today I'm giving you some
off the bat I'm offering you 50% off of
your first tour when you go to nature
box.com slash Joe we make sure you get
the no and they sent me a box last week
delish I didn't give you dick I'm sorry
I know I never get an A tomorrow honey
you know what happened the beef jerky oh
my god the jalapeno sweet jalapeno thats
get Jesus Christ anyway that's
naturebox.com/tyler and I'm gonna give
you 50% off your first order again
naturebox calm down
what goes up must come down and what
goes in must go out the reason why I'm
talking to you right now is I've been
telling you this for about a year but
now I'm gonna drop it on you but days
are back when you're writing your little
Santa list this year tell that
[ __ ] one thing that he still owes
your money and to that all you want for
Christmas is you [ __ ] the [ __ ] be
spotless clean when you got access pine
cones coming out of your [ __ ] muff
ler and fudgy [ __ ] smell all over unholy
night you need a Toshiba day all right
what's up a day a bidet is portable you
snap it on your toilet and after you
take the [ __ ] at that
you'd push the button and water hits
your [ __ ] and let me tell you some
you kill three birds with one stone I
have one of those man how [ __ ] good
it's like a fire hose it's tremendous
totally it screams yes better they
toilet paper on the [ __ ] market all
right and it cleans deep deep deep you
spread those cheeks like your own coca
you're about to put in a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you don't give a [ __ ] and you let that
cold water did that [ __ ] libido
whatever the [ __ ] you got net and then
you give it one last white but it's all
over you understand me
yeah [ __ ] tip-top Magoo or you
needed somebody to take the small 22
lick that [ __ ] Mitch play with
monthly and I'm saying cuz it's the
holidays so do me a favor what I'm gonna
do for you right now is this $69 Santa
could afford that stop wiping that nasty
[ __ ] ass and you got a clean ass with
Russia go - hello - she calm right now
and use code church for 10% off your
order again hello - she calm right now
let's get this [ __ ] party
started [ __ ] tremendous happy Monday
[ __ ] this is one of my favorite
parts but there's a lot of reasons I
love seeing you one of them every time I
see you or come to your podcast you
always will put me on to like a movie I
haven't seen before or know about or
some or some music that's like making
the drive for no reason if I could love
it man
it over in the house looking from the
beautiful thanks brother handsome dapper
you got my favorite crayon [ __ ]
we sigh at next to him fine with you you
looking dapper over from the side you
stole the glue CJ I hope you don't pick
your dick down
as the family families great men so your
little boys going on to Italy to just
can't wait it's the bestest acutest
little [ __ ] winter changes that
you've noticed inside of you
like what now when you get on a plane
you don't kid cries you don't want to
kick that lady in the head no yeah it
completely changes your yeah you have
empathy help people you see yeah you see
a lady with a like two bags and a baby
and and she's what you you'll run to get
the door I mean now that you wouldn't
before but like you you're you're
keeping an eye out for it cuz you
recognize it man and you have definitely
empathy for the crying babies for sure
like you definitely have changed with
that part cuz you you can't help it man
you know it's crazy how people are
getting called out for things they did
15-20 years ago yeah and for some people
I get it and for some others I don't get
it and the reason why I was married I
had a child I had a child till the age
of three you know I was in her life till
the age of five if you know I was there
as much time as I could do but I wasn't
the same available mmm I was not the
same animal
not even close I was a failure of a man
at that point my life compared to who
and how I think now yeah and I see a guy
like you you know your late thirties you
spin out your first child your wife its
supreme when it's like
I've seen the changes in you you know a
little things you want more focus what
do you feel inside as a dad like that's
man it's hard to put into words man it
really is yeah it's like because it's
like it sounds it sounds cliche but all
those cliche things ultimately are
usually true and that's why I mean
there's there's true through people
repeat them you know but it's like I
mean the you know your kids like it's
all you think about when you've got it
when you get up in the morning it's like
your sole focus and you think about them
when you go to bed it becomes like just
the driving force in your life I think
so like you know it's just it changes
everything that is crazy cuz I know
there's a lot of Lissa's right now
yeah sure we don't give a [ __ ] about you
yeah [ __ ] kids yeah yeah that's great
you're not gonna give a [ __ ] today but
one day you're gonna be in the hospital
room holding your child and you're gonna
think of Tom I'm me telling you this
that yeah it makes you it put put does
it take the blinders on it was to take
them off
what's the haha man you get ya like you
you get hyper [ __ ] almost paranoid
about [ __ ] man like you start things
that you'd ignored you're like I got you
you just think about it all I mean from
like [ __ ] safety you know like it's
as everything secure here to like what's
good what we gonna do when we get on
that plane you start thinking about what
if somebody I don't always want to
protect the kid no matter what you know
from other kids other adults the world
was a parking lot there's a big yeah
yeah yeah and how was he reacting at the
park oh it's awesome
he loves the park me he loves you know
he's [ __ ] he's uh he's super active
he's big running around like he's just
he's a he loves playing man so I mean we
take him to classes and he loves all
that [ __ ] dude
what's his sleeping habits he's down to
one nap a day basically goes down for a
nap every day around let's say 130
sleeps furred on a great day two hours
but usually less than that and then at
night he goes to bed at 7:00 and he gets
up at 7:00
Wow 12 hours Jesus Christ without mercy
last night I got up I don't know what
happened I tell a lot of you know weeks
of dead quiet I go what I do a lot of
exercise yeah so I went to a couple
jiu-jitsu with my buddies and got beat
up and you go to how you like that
really really do yeah and this guy I've
been because I can't call it a 12
o'clock classes as I'm busy now right
and so I gotta go to my buddies at 3:00
and it's tremendous it really is the
last thing I think I overdid a little
bit for my age and last night I fell
asleep at 7:00 my my my my niece came
into town with a boyfriend it was just
Thanksgiving was we drove to her vine
it's exhausting then we drove back they
were there we stayed up till one talk
and got up the next morning was Thursday
people came over I tried to help my wife
as much as I could
Friday they went to Universal I trained
I wrote a little bit I hooked up with
them fried and I took him for Cuban food
they went [ __ ] nuts I shot the Cuban
sandwich commercial form Okochi NATO and
Silver Lake has just become superb you
you are when I tell you they have great
more you go to a place the Spanish you
eat something whatever nationality you
could be with your Irish will you German
and Gary and you know yeah you know
excuse me and you eat something
and you always look for the way your
Russian grandmother made yeah yeah
Argentinian uncle
nothing ever compares right as a matter
of fact sometimes it's shitty and you
get insulted like in Tagalog yeah gets
insulted and this feelings get hurt
and immediately Floridita not like
Floridita oh good about to say that used
to be my spot when I lived in Hollywood
that every ether on Melrose that one
like on on East Melrose know this
there's a Cuban restaurant that's
popular the food is horrible it's
probably around Mondays because people
go dance there that's the one in the
heart of Hollywood
that's a Florida though I don't know
what it's called okay then these are the
ones I know about they say the best one
isn't called the city but there's one on
motor and Venice that's the one you go
to film verse I think I said boy oh
that's what the guy said there boy yeah
that's a different one of my favorite
thing man just ate the [ __ ] bones
yeah yeah at me too I hate I hate having
to stop and I'd be like the bone playing
and now I got the [ __ ] chicken grease
on my for not in the whoo yeah yeah you
know so I like the Google oh yeah
right on Viva and a man so this place
this floor that I never told you about
this late
well I for cochinita was a spot I
discovered my second month in town
thought you need to hook I'm I'm sitting
there with my niece
Felicia Michaels my wife my nieces
boyfriend yeah we're drinking sangria
would sit man you ever going to like
that you ever watch a movie and the guy
goes into like a thought yeah I know how
did I end up out cochinita paid I went
to an audition
I saw Rudy Moreno at the audition it was
close big TV drops yeah it's gotta be
March of 97 I'm in a borrowed car like I
had no money I think in those days I
used to borrow Doug Stanhope s-- utility
car and you didn't know how much gas was
in it because the the needle was the
hole was broken so you got a as soon as
you got in the car you had to put ten
bucks in there and so that's what he
then I went for this [ __ ] audition
what on the five you know these
directions I don't know about and I end
up on the way back go to the audition I
hate a bag of dicks and I ended up in
Echo Park the one that the water spits
out but as I'm driving I know this
police helicopters are all around me
right yeah and I keep driving like I you
know I don't know what the [ __ ] going
on what was going on was decide I was
driving on and I don't know what I was
going north to south people please or
Western looked I was going this way over
here there was a police pursuit have you
been that go part not a while but yeah
Echo Park has a two-block Cuban
neighborhood that you go to Cuban
pastries at this time I knew I know
about this I don't know dick all I know
is I hear stop police so I pulled my car
over and I hear a hairball and then look
oh when I see the guy on the floor and
there's ten cops and there's a cop this
this is doctor in the afternoon on a
[ __ ] Tuesday okay I'm living my own
[ __ ] business
this could only happen to me but
it was after I get back I put my single
on to make a left to go back into the
highway to tying our flight Jesus
I got no ATM I got no money I got a
driver's license in Colorado maybe
[ __ ] four dollars I Drive around the
corner with the flat I parked I call the
only person I know Marilyn Martinez got
arrested so she sends her husband over
he goes don't worry about that guy he
went up to him you go Echo Park and you
go up if you go east every other store
is a Mexican tire place right right
there you go in there whatever you need
they got a tire 20 bucks you know then
you could Jew him down give me ten Oh
Cho not that oh he didn't wear wait wait
yeah so yeah he got me a tire for like
eight bucks
slaps aw Jesus Christ right get the a
tire they slap it on fee if a bus no I'm
healed but on the way back
Marilyn's husband God rest his soul says
to me have you ever met my
brother-in-law the Cuban guy like oh no
he goes he wants to meet you man he just
called prison and he says he knows
people you know and all this [ __ ] mate
all right let's go you are these two by
the way they're both passed with an
arrow and the husband both pass diets or
anything about a Martinez was a common
okay to the husband
damn hey so now we had the political
Cheney go to meet the guy to meet the
dude yeah and I'm [ __ ] I got four
bucks on me he'll order I just got like
a soda I guess I eat you know I'll buy
your lunch so we start talking it was
just a great conversation about being
Cuban yeah and it always ends with if
you ever need anything contact me yeah
yeah Mike what do you mean by anything
and he knows I got the best coconut that
to smell it on you what it because we're
family right thank you yeah so there's a
matter of fact follow me to blogs down
to throw a package in hand okay he threw
a package in my hand for free that night
they've calmly i wanna i went for
coaching the horses it was Doug Stanhope
I mean this all happens in one day and
I'm sitting at the table bored
my life is crazy back then it was me
Doug Stanhope Davis full a comic friend
of ours from Seattle from 95 lives in
England now Josh wolf his brothers we
would go to the store then go to coach
and horses that night I had to cancel
this coke was so good I couldn't even
smoke I remember I had to leave and I
was living in my car and I had to go on
Josh Bolten block park under a tree and
lay back with me two bottles of beer and
ice at that tow 401 doing a little coke
I had jerking off and that was the end
that I'd [ __ ] die that was a great
day sounds like a good yelp review
that's a fantastic review time I [ __ ]
wish it was like today jerking off out
of a window in a car that [ __ ] coke
was good so did you hit him up again oh
yeah that night when that [ __ ] wore off
I made up some story I gave somebody
like a bumper to and they went crazy
they cocaine was off limits like this
[ __ ] was just it was how much were you
doing at your max of coke like when you
were really and this was probably 97
yeah and I was broke but I could still
get 20s from time to time and at that
time I was doing three four twenties a
week
okay then I pop the Taco Bell
commercially resolved oh really
yeah it was one of the first one with
the dog and then you're like getting 4x
yeah I was just going to the dudes house
but at that time I always hunted away
just like weed to get I met people who
did cocaine and appreciate it yeah
there's people who were just Salman but
there's people willing listen you gotta
come over here now
and bring whatever cash we got with you
cuz I usually get [ __ ] wait till you see
the [ __ ] and they were not [ __ ] with
you
and then I [ __ ] when you go over there
this [ __ ] is from 1980 the flake the
ether base you know if you learned in
narcos in the season 3 then yeah you
really enjoy yeah yeah go to buy the
ether yeah there was no ether at one
point in 85 cocaine was always
tremendous and always tasted delicious
that drip yeah when you went up to the
bar and had that [ __ ] Budweiser Jesus
Christ and your throat would get numb
and your their [ __ ] I wouldn't even
smoke in that but that was a time by
8687
yeah that cocaine started getting funky
mm-hmm started smelling like turpentine
and [ __ ] shoe polish and it was so
good but the next day he kinda had a
headache from whatever the [ __ ] you were
snoring the night before gasps Oh a knee
because they couldn't get enough ether
is because there was like a cutoff right
someone like somebody the supplier they
couldn't get enough fish like then at
that point they were making so much
cocaine goddamn and they couldn't get
enough teeth I never knew romanticizes
to the point where I want to try I knew
at that point I knew what was going on
like I wouldn't miss people go ha number
I used to fly back and forth with Danny
B who calls them to the podcast yeah I
used to fly back and forth with packages
at one time I went the same legal listen
oh this guy usually wants nines at that
time he wanted her
86 and 9600 for a quarter kilo which at
that time was whatever comes out the
nine and a half I have no idea I'm not a
mathematician the price dropped by 2000
he goes if you want because I'll get you
that one but try this [ __ ] for two
thousand less it might work for you and
he brought it over [ __ ] the coke put
me in another planet there was only one
problem it's about my [ __ ] campus
really oh my god in a horrible way
really and guess what the Jew Cuban did
well I brought that campus back we did
and no matter what you color with it was
campus and people were bringing him back
to me
people like he can so that was the coat
that you bought and turned into crack
the cap has to happen because they're
little they don't give a [ __ ] they're
smoking it yeah it'll taste that cap it
doesn't take a piss when you smile then
there was a period but when you snort it
what it sticks with you it sticks with
you like it's just you know if this is
smell good like yeah it just doesn't
smell good what is regular coke smelling
delicious paradise but I really [ __ ]
paradise would eat the ether based
gokane it smells good 80 79 through 86
how hard was it to quit coke it was easy
because I was done you know a ring like
that was done like that at that point I
had a lot of variables Y and it was a
lot easier than people think I was done
once I just I missed I realized that I
wasn't getting high to get it wasn't
enjoyable Doughboy like marijuana right
now I could see a fallen off the map
anything really
yeah I can see myself I can see myself
just doing had a bull's-eye song calm me
down for a while just to save a little
bit of lung I got left
oh it stopped smoking doesn't take a
genius to know I got the beginning of
sort of the same you know like you know
you don't have to be a genius so you can
do it then do that man and that's what
uh with cocaine it was the same thing I
just knew that when you I was doing
cocaine for so long I was getting jolts
in my spine that the other day night
jolts of electricity like Castro's in
bed what is that bad it's terrified
that's not good that's not nice Christ
that means you're like yes that me and I
was getting war tonight
you know once a week and then it started
to get to a night that's [ __ ]
terrorist I started to a night I could
just see my wife waking up to go pee and
seeing my fat little legs in the kitchen
waiting they're purple and you're like
yeah you know I said I can't do it so
that was you have to know you have to be
an early 50s self at one point wait I
wanted to ask you this we're jumping
back what what's the what's the great
dish I don't got you neat though there's
a bunch of them but didn't you have a
favorite you were saying I think I had
to pioneer the other yeah now the paya
do I rank it and what I grew up at
Segovia and move on a new jersey and in
the place in the city
yeah when my mom took me to I ran to the
six but they're in the ballpark and that
impresses me yeah the chorizo is good it
says special on Fridays okay
I usually go for the [ __ ] if I go
there and get the pork chops as much as
I don't like eating pork out they do it
perfect yeah I'd be perfect Moss at that
boy cool with white rice and black beans
I'm too old to eat the fried bananas so
I'll admit that I don't get too old for
them yeah after a while it's not bad if
you look I'm up on Weight Watchers and
[ __ ] yeah it's not like they kill you
but you're trying to avoid all but a
fried food sure you heat the port you
sacrifice to fried banana and you don't
need to [ __ ] bread and butter and
when you order the flan which is a tenth
the flan there is but here's the thing
that they're what I love about a
restaurant is I'll stay with you if
you're a five and if you're nice people
and if every time I go in there as a
table and if I'm in an aisle and the
waitresses are nice yeah the place is
clean I'll stay with you because I don't
like shopping around if it's a five or
six that went from being a five or six
to Atlanta Oh Ted I'm telling you this
over the [ __ ] two years like the last
seven meals I've had
left there going jesus [ __ ] christ
that was good
whoa now i'm people argue out some guy
was telling him once how they get their
beans out of a can i went to another
popular place come on we should go where
the beans would dick dick but where is
this coach me a trial on Sunset
Boulevard okay like on a silver lake
I'll buy coke but that okay I guess it's
hip now the hip stuff it's next to a
baskin-robbins okay you know it's it's
very hip now so on Fridays guy hit the 7
o'clock but I will tell you one thing I
had six people with me ain't ranked I'm
the designated driver
yeah I'm 300 pounds alcohol does nothing
to me
yeah I got a picture of sangria dog it
was the biggest [ __ ] picture of
sangria I ever saw in my life no people
would tap it out you know like Jesus
Christ how much sangria it was filter
brim I had like a piece of pineapple I
couldn't drive my wife I Drive really
what happened I had a piece of pie lamp
I [ __ ] up jack it's not the juice to
get you it's that fruit they let's it
dogs [ __ ] right and let that [ __ ]
[ __ ] we were talking right before you
said to hold it I was asking you if in
prison if different races had different
foods like that were a priority for them
that like they like oh you know it's
[ __ ] Wednesday's you know mac and
cheese the [ __ ] Asians are gonna go
nuts today or whatever like was there
anything that like different races
prioritized food wise in prison or that
they desired you know when I got to
county and diagnostic there's a list you
get a sheet on Tuesday night yeah this
is 1987 people if you're in prison now
or what I'd rather go how the [ __ ] has
done that and on Tuesday night when you
got arrested you usually got 22 dollars
on you then your mother puts a $50 bill
they get sedative oh yeah so it's called
the commissary yeah so on that
commissary this toothpaste toothbrush
comb gel deodorant big bag of Cheetos
Ding Dongs you know they got a bucket of
this [ __ ] yeah it's 50 a week delivered
there
yeah Haiti a week so living that you
know and on Thursday night they make Tom
Segura it made 68 check yourself oh by
the way they were out of Cheetos Lisa at
bought 25 bags that [ __ ] because
then he'll sell them on the black market
right you're following me right right no
charge of the Cheetos serving that when
you go by the leaf sellers or watch your
fat dudes lurking waiting room thought
was the Cheetos that machine you know
yeah so that's how it wasn't those
systems for you to and I don't remember
think of bringing your food and
visitation the but it was very
interesting for me because well I got
sets they told me to my face you were
not gonna see a state prison until
December you were gonna go to a County
Jail you mean they're gonna go to rifle
which is down underneath you only have
windows it's really like this shiny
Jesus it snows a lot and when I take a
cable TV the [ __ ] like that and at that
time there was another place or you
could sign a waiver and get sent to
Texas or some other place there was
brief days for one something crazy so I
didn't say nothing my attorney never
mentioned it I got sentenced August 15th
so I figure [ __ ] I'll be in Boulder till
maybe October and then October though
shipped me to Ohio or a rifle and then
by December are gonna diagnostic but by
that time it doesn't matter
because those days and County at two for
the price of one so six months in county
already is 12 months I had a I had e it
counts like that they tell you that no
that's the rule that's the rule
so at that time okay I had a 48 month
sentence right okay which is four years
yeah my sentencing the do I sign was six
- for four years - six no zero to six
that's what it was it was depending on
the judge zero the six was the deal I
signed I could get six years I get three
years I get four years probation
but there was nothing more than six
years that's the deal I signed that was
in I signed to second-degree burglary at
- accessory to a felony that's what the
plea was I'd plea bargain with my and I
still give him props that was one of the
best attorneys because what was the
worst case scenario that they were
kidnapping - nine years and Federer and
it's offended and it's a toss-up with
the feds one at number one yeah and
number two it's a violent crime which I
need you served 3/4 of your sentence man
Authority mandatory and you got a parole
one year they definitely hold you back
yeah probably done a is for sure
[ __ ] and they were going for it they
were going heavy for it but I knew the
victim was weak and he was getting
weaker by the day he was snorting more
in fact he called me we've been playing
phone tag lately really yeah we've been
probably pologize the whole thing I
remember when you apologized yeah but
then I still kept in touch with him he
still [ __ ] with him
no I there's no reason to [ __ ] when he
was in his own how I have a funny
feeling yeah and I love dearly believe
it or not you know I'm a nobody is I've
learned to love the daily PS you just
passed the anniversary of something
right so that's how you tweet like this
was thirteen years was you
I did the crime 30 years ago yeah like
last week so yeah it was 30 years ago so
that's what pisses me off what's going
on right now that people accusing people
at things that did 15 years ago Tom you
know that type of [ __ ] bothers me
Braga's we all change yeah I know I must
weigh different [ __ ] than I was
at 34 at 34 I was on intercom me but I
could still muggy if I had to the other
fan yeah I had two kilos of coke and you
were [ __ ] around with Lee up here uh
guess who's coming at 3:00 with a gun to
mug his boat you really would you really
were doing that I would either do it
with a mask on or or get two people to
do it on a cap to take well and you'd
figure out it was me eventually sure I
did that type of [ __ ] right twice and
then got caught with the kidnapping I
lucked out on from that diaper and then
so it's good that you got caught then
when I got out of prison
20 years later three years later buddy
of mine came to me to listen I got an
angle these guys they got this amount
you kicked the door did you tell him who
you are they give it to you know we hang
tough when we walk out and thumps ago I
did it one time did yes and it was
horrible I thought my heart beat he did
[ __ ] go deaf it was terrible and I
ran out there I came back the bag I'm
like [ __ ] you why that was HIPAA these
guys were pros at it this is what they
did is what they were doing there was
shaking down people all over the while
to know you like I guess I think that's
what like people don't understand like
to know you but that's why they allowed
me but I wasn't a violent person
yeah I was just a confused individual I
was just confused yeah and I was lucky
because confusion means you're gonna end
up dead or in jail I was [ __ ]
fortunate bro to go to jail yeah I was I
was fortunate to go to jail on a day
but I mean that knowledge I learned
though she is doing mission I was doing
out there is crazy that's a complete
different [ __ ] world for me that I
can't even transfer to somebody like I
wish like I could somebody said to me
listen on your license now sign away
that piece of your brain because we want
to go through it and analyze it to see
what you saw it's mind-boggling
yeah it was really really out there at
that time in the education I took from
me you know when you think of I was out
back to the food yeah yeah so yeah yeah
okay once you hit diagnostic and love
once you hit diagnostic and you go to
where you're supposed to go now you have
visitation mmm
now willing to be a little racist and
what we're gonna be a little husband
okay I worked in the kitchen okay I
think there was one Mexican kid and
everybody else's spring black okay and
then you and you'll actually great those
white guys in the kitchen I got along
with all what you do in the case how was
this I started as a baker but I was
making the cinnamon rolls and I almost
blew up the place because he told me to
make him this big I don't know I just
put this bed yeah and it came out like
those [ __ ] things you throw in the
Olympics yeah so they said we need a
dishwasher slash stock clerk and then
they fired me as admitted fire me as a
dishwasher I had a driver's license yeah
so they wanted me to drive this van
which is to wait we have a good your
drive and you see convicts cleaning the
side yeah sure I would drop sandwiches
off 12:00 dude that's my job give
someone like where they got at you
you're doing that no no no this is some
this is minimum minimum without security
oh so they just know you're gonna come
back so I got 48 months yeah but
automatically it gets cut to two because
you do in the jail time because it's
just a way light out
okay so Foley that's why when you hear
he's getting this [ __ ]
that's right well I hear the sentence
I'll tell you it was [ __ ] than that
so I got four years automatically it's
24 months I had already done a month in
Cali so it's two months it's had 22
months yeah
by the time I got sentence I had 22 much
well guess what yeah I was before a
halfway house at 18 months but time he
was 16 months you're in a halfway house
yeah so I had ain't once to do some
maybe but at the time of sentencing he
told me he wanted a letter after 90 days
for reconsideration of my sentence
because I'd never been in trouble before
yeah yeah I had a bunch accusation so
the judge said that yeah well so I had
three different things going for me you
follow me now so back to the original
question cuz I thought about this guy
today
I thought about a guy who hated me in
prison remember the season of Sons of
Anarchy what's Chuck Zito Chuck Zito
yeah Chuck Zito supposed to be a really
nice guy I have a lot of friends
mutual friends well when I got locked up
there was a biker dude in there that
acted just like Chuck Zito did on Sunday
Anik he had the rings and the long hair
the sunglasses and one day I'll never
forget this vividly he picked an
argument with me about the song from
Guns and Roses about mr. brownstone yeah
I told him it's about heroin mm-hmm and
then he had like four of his little
[ __ ] [ __ ] soldiers with yeah the
problem why he couldn't lift the hand to
me was and he says I married a woman
named Terry Clark but I had to read
dudes I was tight with in prison at this
facility that had 146 then they would
bust you up
one guys was a white dude so freely
named John Clark did not look
threatening a menacing at all he had
just done nine years and he left bodies
dropped the whole system why he was a
legend of the prison system he wasn't a
bike
he was Alerian he was just a tough white
dirt yeah
all right he was a math dude and he had
a girlfriend he was out of Philly on a
Monday visitation she would come and
bring it in her mouth and they would
swap spit and I would go back to his
room and he'd give me two lines of
[ __ ] Mets he was my dawg dawg he was
my Goomba I loved that dog yeah though
on the other side I was in the kitchen
because it was army barracks so I was on
the other side so the army barrack I was
in was the kitchen army barrack all
y'all all brothers right they were all
brothers and they were all the brothers
from the kitchen but the main dude in
the kitchen I got again the main orders
was Spencer Antwon aka Chicken Hawk
you didn't [ __ ] with him he was never
involuntary manslaughter he really
killed the [ __ ] yeah but he had
money and he paid the attorney I really
let the [ __ ] with chicken well not to
mention he was just a solid do it yeah
he loved me called me Cuba
I loved him if I call him like a
stepfather I would really yeah he had
six kids you know he was a real dude he
was just a black dude that was out
drinking a bottle of wine one day and in
front of his neighborhood some people
got loud with him and they said some
tours why would he stabbed a
[ __ ] you know plain and simple
happens yeah and then there was an
Italian dude that was a mobster but he
really wasn't this guy I think about him
once a month because if I got a cop uh
explain the top ten guys haven't met my
life that was a smooth as guys ever yeah
he's number five or six really not a
good-looking dude without a handsome
dude no drugs no alcohol Italian dude
pure extortionist
that was his angle Tom Segura isn't Who
I am this is what I do you doing this
you doing this from now on you're doing
him in this envelope every month
as a nut I'm gonna put your bullet in
your mother's [ __ ] head [ __ ] with a
part of [ __ ] the Impaler yeah those
dudes Jesus but he was a [ __ ] he had
just done like 14 years I found out
about him through an account for him and
I just used to talk a lot Mondays he's
to go hey kid you hungry on Mondays I
cook and he was a tremendous cook even
make nachos with [ __ ] stoves and
ovens and [ __ ] I mean don't ask I'm
Catholic
but he also ran the numbers done the
sports betting business in that and he
was Italian
he wasn't googlebot up yeah he could
just know he was Italian
and they didn't really the Mexicans and
the blacks didn't mix on him so I went
to him to tell him answer question give
me one of those sheets I started selling
them because I mingled with chickenhawk
because he was black I mingled with John
Clark cuz he was wife okay so I had a
mole and I mingled with the Mexicans
because I was Spanish yeah so I had
everybody gambling so now I started
turning over to cards so this guy
started becoming his food was free to me
that was part of the deal from now on
whatever you cook and he used to make
[ __ ] in there every day
[ __ ] every day every day every day
because we all had access to the store
man I love when now we had black dudes
in there that was solid as [ __ ] yeah and
one of the dudes that was in there on
Sundays this is the question you're
asking is your answer yes the Mexicans
were bringing [ __ ] burritos that
would tear delicious and there was one
family the Anaya's there was the uncle
and nephew were imprisoned together they
didn't really like each other
two Mexicans ran out of American me they
would look at each other like what what
fool
yeah they [ __ ] hate each other it's
an uncle - nephew and then they both
ended up in the same prison for some
dumb crime they both did I was tight
with the uncle the uncle me he loved me
so his mom and sister so when they would
eat the whole family would come for
visitation yeah and bring them food but
the dude the uncle would sell me tacos
no burritos green chili mashed potatoes
with [ __ ] pork in them oh and I would
buy him and I give it buy some and I
should've bought 20 of them yeah like
that's like I would buy four yeah yeah
and take two in my room and have like a
black-and-white TV in my room you know I
could eat twenties then I would just
tell him on Sunday I want to what any go
well you gotta give me a premium done
and I'll give you extra food from the
kitchen God bleep up I get 20 [ __ ]
plenty oh there were little yeah there
were a little ones but they whatever
Moses people are perfect and the black
dude that was my Goomba was a young [ __ ]
and he's his girlfriend's each he had
seven different freaks Jesus he had
seven women on his payroll ladies and
gentlemen okay ladies and gentlemen
seven women and they'll have his babies
this was way before baby mama was even
discussed they were his [ __ ] and all
of me she had a Subaru or this or that
of this and each had his kids and he
would make all of them bring him
church's chicken Popeyes Chicken and
other butters like a [ __ ] so he
would see me and hit me in the signing
of Cuba I'm stocked up on another but
his legs slowing by and I would go into
his little ghetto little trailer and
learn how it going through his room when
we'd sit there and watch TV wasn't the
batter we listen to too short
really and he's not a butters [ __ ]
tremendous tremendous
tremendous that's not what they make it
out to be like no because it's once you
go the way you go you have to get a wall
yeah
if not if you [ __ ] up Lee you [ __ ] it up
for everybody so that [ __ ] they show you
in the movies is a lot of controversy at
times sometimes you go those places and
that peaceful is [ __ ] because they
don't want they did they have certain
liberties in your imagine being in this
room for twenty four [ __ ] hours or a
month well and it's not even this room
cut it off at that camera right there
your toilets right here with a
black-and-white TV a little bed with ten
I picture your cat and you do push-ups
and sit-ups and [ __ ] it upside down lips
you think that's exciting
no no it sounds horrible variable but
you have the racial groups and the
racial group stick together and guess
what I was not involved in drugs in
there I knew some white dudes that have
acid that's it because they drug tested
you and you have to run with a racial
group get the relevancy they know I ran
through the way I've run from my life
yeah I know everybody yeah I don't know
nobody but I know I know everybody I
don't talk to go and is this I'm friends
with Lee and he's Jewish that's never
really affected me yeah sure do I go him
do I get excited around my Spanish roots
yes I do sometimes I'm more my Spanish
roots I really get excited you know and
just it brings me back sure
it brings your footing back as they say
I think it's like it's the one of the
things I get a kick out of that show the
narco show in season three is that it's
Colombian but they speak like really
similar of Peruvian Spanish so it's part
of the reason like I love the show is
that they speak that specific style
slang all that gets me like fired up the
guy in New York is my favorite oh that
guy do you know that he's [ __ ]
Brazilian or Portuguese the the New York
Colombian guy either
he'd learned Spanish for that he speaks
Portuguese so his uh so was the guy who
played Pablo yeah but the guy that the
New York guy his Spanish was
unbelievable phenomena the the guy that
played Pablo terrible in it they got
better the second season she was harmed
that dude was [ __ ] really good don't
really enjoy those Spanish shows I
listened I watched all 80 episodes of
celeea did you realize cheesy as a god
at some points yeah because you download
and watch one appointment yeah on a
plane it's really the only place where
you can focus on a movie and really
catch you check out Lewis laws and [ __ ]
like that
you still traveling what no me yeah yeah
but it's winding down thank god this
year was heavy travel man really heavy
but like I'm happy that I'm almost down
we were traveling heavy for 10 years
yeah 10 years of steady traveling a lot
at a rally it already wears on me man
like it's already like I'm I'll try to
think of like I already figured out what
I [ __ ] up this year to try to do
differently next time I'm heavily Tory
you know I still remember 98 to 2000 I
pretty much lived on the road yeah I
didn't have an appointment here on a p.o
box I had all my checks sent to Josh
Wolf's house he really kind of whatever
clothes I would wear I would send I
would buy new clothes every two or three
weeks from different cities and send the
old clothes home - Josh Wolfson he would
that was the craziest ever not even you
guys have history man yeah this is this
was 98 99 even 99 2000 I left
November of 99 and I came back April
2000
yeah mm six months without being home
now that's [ __ ] unbearable at speech
or act
go ahead lining and lighter that's it
wherever whenever
snow tires or a must [ __ ] oh seven I
did like man like close to 40 weeks of
feature work and I just racked up that
dude like just because I knew there's no
other way to know if I did I did listen
I did five years of each act feet to
work and I enjoyed don't your [ __ ] was a
blast man I got good I got really good
and I learned rooms I bond I bombed a
lot as a feature did you yeah payment
picture it with you it took a while it
took me were you dirty cause like you're
dirty but like it's hot you're it's not
dirty for the sake of dirty it feels
genuine no I don't know at that time I
was pushing it like but were you dirty
yes you were dirty middle act uh yeah
ninety five month I was edgy a little
dirty of a topical nothing personal
that's where the cuts where the cover
you wasn't it really wasn't there there
was nothing personal and then once I
moved to Seattle that open mic opened me
up a little bit but it was accomplished
or that really late night if you really
really want to get good go there 12:30
puck 12:30 six nights a week for two
months you'll come up with [ __ ] you will
never thought do you have in you really
I keep hearing people say that I mean
for me it was I think I were out I think
if I did get this special I would just
tell how to midnight Thursday through
Saturday Tuesday through Friday that's
what you'd want to run it no that's what
I want to work work it out work that's
work and it's really it's all work it's
different work it's a different thing
going to an open mic these people pain
so you still got probably heat yeah but
you get put yourself in a weird
situation where those little jabs you
throw three little short jabs and one of
them is really good so you got something
out of the night yeah the calm you still
work out you know that that thing that
Brody doesn't stuff that single guy
stuff you know won't come in your door 2
a.m. yeah three nights a week that's
[ __ ] heavy if I gotta get up at 8:00
with the girl oh my god I'm done that
means I don't live in a clock I'm
[ __ ] spreading Jack I can't even sit
out you know yeah but that's a spot that
really opens you up that 11:45 midnight
following somebody would just did heat
yeah and you gotta go up there your
development area sure your mind will
really race real quick you know it just
happened to stammer the [ __ ] stay out
till 12:00 well you built yeah this
young man's game feel young man's game
his little hat factory he's doing like
45 we do it 10 15 at The Improv and you
close out this for 4-6 weeks yeah you're
unstoppable and the Midwest doesn't see
your material here there's these coasts
so what you don't door by Melos so the
[ __ ] summertime he just makes sense
yeah well how was that the store I was
just [ __ ] around
ah and she just goes well well you want
to get paid I don't wanna die just I'm
the last guy can you do this like on a
week week night Thursday through
Saturday just let me come in and close
it out close her out
it doesn't matter what time would you go
in 10:30 you just run a half hour 20
minutes yeah you know points 20 minutes
of whatever different type of audience
yeah it's a it's it's a lot of great
training thing is again will a single
you want to come up with a great half
hour wait 45 minutes go to New York and
do midnight shows Oh midnight the - baby
boy yeah four or five from you know
three sets baby boy you do three of
those twelve to two that's what [ __ ]
are he's done he moved there and starts
did I talk to him the week he's up doing
like six spots some nights but good
thing but see you don't understand I
used to play [ __ ] tennis with Doug
Stanhope and Mitch Hedberg tennis with
them when I first moved here the hot
thing was to go to Gorky Park
unfastening Vista down there there's a
park now they've redone and cleaned up
oh that was you by a nickel bags out of
it you can buy $20 bag of weed on the
other side either by the benches we just
go and play tennis and I'll never forget
what they Mitch Hedberg Don you know I
move in New York I know I think that's a
great [ __ ] idea and he goes why no
because everybody looks like me and
you're like you got even own more
[ __ ] story
I am
we only is so [ __ ] how deep are you
right now how many no I'm just we need
two things that's wrong in going around
a couple stars of death leaves about the
okay I think we're so are you ripped in
half though I'm all ripped in half I'm
ripped up a piece and trailing listen we
call the training yet you call it
training you guys do I told what would
you guys call it so October yeah sup
October we do a year-round 24/7 that's
how much you think that would be [ __ ]
horrific to try what's that so sobriety
sober for a month or would holy yeah for
you at this point I'm looking I'm the
type of guy don't like talking about it
yeah you just put three days you yell at
people
yeah call everybody a [ __ ] yeah
and then one day you like Jesus Christ
you know maybe I could do this and you
go for seven days no but you're saying
like under the rate like don't make it a
big thing yeah yeah no I hear you you
know
I gonna you know I'm gonna digits you
gotta put that robot yeah have you put
that in your bag on it's wet you know
you're you're [ __ ] me undies are wet
you sweat at THC out you know yeah or
just important to my it's importantly
you know just to be able to mobile yeah
what level what the [ __ ] we talking
about I don't know Mitch Hedberg moving
in New York tennis hotspot OS that's
what it was doing a midnight spot so
that's what all he's doing hey oh that's
the one yeah
when Harvey talked to me about moving to
New York listen Ari has always been a
night out yeah there are some people who
that stay game and don't funk I have a
friend I grew up with knocked on his
door at 2:00 in the morning it's a
parade it's like [ __ ] 8 the morning
for some people yeah there's 4 feet yes
look of the state yeah you're like what
are you going like yeah I have a friend
when I grew up with him if you locked on
his door at 1:00 he's not gonna get him
you know not gonna heaven because he
wouldn't even turn the light off till
7:00 in the morning
but yeah he was one of those guys those
guys did tremendous like all going all
night he would well that my roommate my
roommate in college this kid would be up
all night and then go to class and play
football and I'd be like how aren't you
exhausted he goes I don't need that much
sleep in I don't need that much sleep
and he would just I mean I would get up
to take a piss I'm talking I'm in school
and I'm staying up you know kinda late
like past midnight but I get to take a
piss at 4:00 in the morning lights are
on musics on in his room he's just like
just [ __ ] hanging out you know just
like that's how that's how he would just
go through and then go to class had a
girlfriend played football he just he he
would sell to us that he needed very
little sleep I don't understand how you
do it I don't how you operate man and
like he was a fully functioning like nah
no not a not somebody here like this
guy's not all there he just didn't need
it he just
he could just run on these fumes and it
didn't really catch up with him I never
understood it so that went home every
time I go home I see this guy if I have
blood in this world he's one of those
guys I love him like a brother
[Music]
for 30 years you couldn't finger about
but I learned that literally aids just
don't let people be themselves right
like I always had that I don't know why
I remember I go to drink beers with
these guys these guys would be bitching
about this guy and I go how is it
hurting
well because you know he support this
guy was 20 21 he was no well he was
about 15 I met him yeah never became
friends probably family he had [ __ ]
three brothers and three sisters bro in
the house and one day I'm talking to him
about something else hey you got 10
minutes
come let me show you something we
[ __ ] walk through a back of his house
and we moved some [ __ ] and we open up a
door neighbors look at this and he
doesn't what do you think I don't know
what he talking about at that time my
mother died I told he was suggesting I
move in there it was just a blank space
with [ __ ] my [ __ ] or everywhere I
think I was I'm thinking of building
this and moving down here I worked a
lumberyard at the time so I had access
to wood paneling carpeting the whole
thing we measured it and one day I told
I got a [ __ ] City truck and he
[ __ ] came down we loved it everything
everything he needed amazes he from
[ __ ] lighting to be bailed to build
his the first original mancave 1980 okay
everything was brand new
b-ball couches he bought a [ __ ] the
last piece you thief snort coke
he bought a TV which he built into a
wall
he had a reel-to-reel he had tremendous
speakers at this time he worked on the
sporting goods and at night he worked at
the local deli from 6:00 to 10:00
loading the liquor and registration yeah
and the guy who owned the place was a
[ __ ] bobberts so if you went over to
the corner of the tent he get in the car
you and he was always ready to go this
guy but there was three or four nights a
week that he wasn't ready to go and he
would take his mother's car and go
somewhere you were you knocked on his
door at 11:00 he wouldn't be home and
then you go back like about 1:30 and you
could see his light on it you'd not put
the glass they'd go go go to the back
and he let him he have let him know and
he went wait you got it man I was
looking for huh so I went to this place
young I got steak upstairs and he would
go upstairs to swipe some snake mistake
and he would roller join that we [ __ ]
eat the steak roll the joint and we're
proud of smoke to join it and we watched
whatever the comedian was on Letterman
and love we both loved let like he
turned me on to let him yeah and then at
the Letterman we put the reel-to-reel
one and we listened to Judas Priest and
I'd sit there with him
till three the morning and then the next
day I'd be up the hatchway
the dolly and somebody would tell me how
they dropped my car for they the morning
I mean how did you drop him off at 8:00
we stopped by his house at 3:30 said
you're just luck we got a shirt we went
over to the city we went over to the
rooftop took fate in the morning fine we
did a bag of blow like he had that type
of lifestyle you know he was just a
night owl yeah hello I love night I love
this like tell me why you enjoy all
right well I'm not reality but me
post-production yeah I had night jobs
from our first couple years here I like
if I did I did graveyard you times oh
it's it's terrible but it's it's a great
way to experience Italy there's no
there's usually no traffic unless they
close the 405 but I like nighttime I
don't know it's just I've always I've
always liked being up late I hate I
don't know I don't I don't like I don't
like being up early yeah I like I was I
was a definitely late night dude oh yeah
oh I mean now it's shifted I get up
early man so I had to shift but for yeah
for a long time I was always up always
up late you know and and I was always
late as I snorted coke right I'll always
be up early tip-top Magoo now is never
that guy before you know I love you
getting up early
yeah I know you you're like let's get
the day started
let's [ __ ] it but here's the thing I
love doing comedy on the road yeah but
I'll tell you what my favorite thing is
why my what do you think that isn't your
favorite thing about being on the road
is sleeping know what what do you think
this uninterrupted work time Friday
night was it time where I was born the
road and I couldn't wait to get our
stage Shrike
it's not coke and maybe wait sister come
over Mele took myself off right now
Friday night means that whatever I got
for lunch
only in half of it was a refrigerator in
a room and Friday legs have two shows I
love these people invite you to do [ __ ]
on Saturday and you're like I'll tell
you what I'll call you in the morning
like you know but in the back of your
head you go back to the room
worst case scenario I'm watching the
wall or a toe Floria yeah I'm watching
three lawn orders that's our bro on time
I'm gonna go back to the room I'm gonna
take a shower
after the second show switches level
sporting pajamas my little sweatpants
and my little hooded [ __ ] sweatshirt
I go outside I smoke that [ __ ] number
as I'm passing through the hall I get an
extra bottle of water I'm not gonna lie
to you there's some other brothers too
little pack the little six-pack I'd take
a six pack up there I eat whatever snack
I have and I love having no
responsibilities yeah yeah there is
nothing better to me than having no
responsibility on Friday night I find a
little bit of five in the morning
doesn't matter right I'll get up at nine
I'm gonna off says like at that free
breakfast I'll get two pieces of white
bread with scrambled eggs bacon I got a
couple old meal I get coffee and I'll go
upstairs or watch another episode of
something that I'll sleep till 2:30
that's me all day yeah get up and drink
another Keurig in your room yep it's
Saturday crank it up a little bit go
over your notes yeah maybe walk down the
corner maybe there's a Jersey Mike's so
I'll take you 15 minutes yeah you're
back to your room you smoked a little
oats yep
you're back you take a shower and guess
what is 6:30 is time ago even though
your two shows on Saturday night
and you're not responsible that's true I
don't like being responding when people
and you feel bad when people invite you
don't sell have a one we're having a
little get-together so if I wake up I
call you I tell you what I hate the most
on the road when anybody basically
anybody asked me to do anything like I
hate when people are like hey you know
you're in town do you want to come over
to our house like on whatever day
Thursday Friday Saturday I'm like you
know do you want to go check out this
museum and like now do like for me on
the road I like keeping my whole life
within like a eight-block radius of the
hotel so even if somebody says like
let's get together and have lunch I'm
like all right do it near where I'm
staying
like don't make me go far don't make me
do an adventure today drive out to your
[ __ ] farm or what like just let me
stay around where I want to be and I
like to do low-energy necessary things I
don't like people asking me to do too
much you know all that [ __ ] drains me
like psychologically mentally what his I
ladies found look and whether Mia Lewis
again why because you're looking like
from the side I love you're playing with
your dick there I live in you dick I
would never down I'm not that type of
rat people have bad days I'm saying yeah
dude I've had a lot of people grab my
deck another complaint one time now I
know I love [ __ ] they have a long that's
a long week for a Franklin grab your
dick they're just gonna squeeze and take
it there's no [ __ ] available they want
to grab your little stomach in one time
to squeeze the other day it'll be metal
but ago saying prayer yes here's the big
thing that's and I want to break it down
for Tom a little bit because
if Tom was on the road with Dave
Chappelle yeah okay
and you're doing three thousand seat
theaters yeah
Tom knows that he's blessed with being
on the tour Tom understands that uh not
a lot of comics have this opportunity
maybe Dave Chappelle goes I'm taking you
out for a whole year cuz yeah three
weekends a month you know I've seen her
on Thursday one on Friday and one on
Saturday and count on a second show yeah
yeah yeah and you're doing 20 in each
one a comic like you and I that we've
always been grounded because this is day
one I know you want some comedy singing
one tours yeah
you've always been grounded you've never
pulled me aside and say hey guess what
last time I did Houston I sold more beer
than Joe Rogan yeah yeah you know those
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah oh you gotta leave
there's a bunch of those more why does
that even matter because in their minds
do you no idea what some comedians think
so you've always been very grounded what
the [ __ ] would talk about it we were
talking about oh oh so so you said you
okay having a feature for Dave Chappelle
right you doing 20 minutes okay it
matters but it doesn't matter matters
what that I'm doing it his show it
matters that you doing his show but in
reality it doesn't matter right I agree
with that you then the other see Dave
Chappelle they're paying 62 from yeah
you know and then at least you know this
going in yeah but my point is you're in
San Francisco with Dave Chappelle
if Joey Diaz is a feature act then you
know through Joe Rogan and he says to
you hey Dawg where you stand you know
how about the four seasons
I don't even know this boy Jesus San
Francisco I'm like listen I'm four
blocks away bro my mother's cooking
human food yeah I'll pick you up at 1:00
to have you back in the hotel by 3:00
you have to do that because you're a
feature act they only want you for 20
minutes yeah that's true even if you
come over smoke a joint go back and take
a nap and still wake up a high it might
even help you out a little bit you won't
be so [ __ ] nervous in front of 4,000
[ __ ] people yeah but that's a
completely different story
you don't need not support and Christine
yeah you're not supporting a child
that's telling them you're not poor yeah
and that's one thing I want people to
understand so you have time to walk the
Fisherman's Wharf and look at Chinese
people here move foot rubs and you have
time to go to Columbus and go to the
track but there becomes a difference now
it becomes a difference where instead of
going as a feature act people are now
paying hard-earned money
22:52 $27 to 35 miles to see you right
so what is Tom Segura do all day he
spends his day at the [ __ ] Museum
with the kid Danny meets Joey Diaz for
snapper 45 minutes away but a time show
ton comes how good this [ __ ] Thompson
we're gonna beat right huh w the truth
there's a man yeah si comic how at seven
o'clock you're gonna go [ __ ] that
traffic from Diaz his house all right
Christine I'm sorry to bother you can
you make a curing make a double with
sugar you know and the first show is
over
and in your mind you can't even wait
you're pissed at your agent even asking
about the second show you know I'm gonna
do a [ __ ] second show and you do a
second show and you know what meant that
whole afternoon because you tried to be
a nice person and go to Joey Diaz his
house or well these ayats' house just
ruin your night's performance because
you weren't on your a-game right
and guess who told me about that [ __ ]
Marilyn Martinez talking about that on
game day but when you're a headliner
it's a different day that totally trades
about Tom Segura he wakes up he eats his
breakfast he reads his paper he calls
his wife he talks to the baby they Skype
ha ha ha I got you Disney at the [ __ ]
Airport you turn it off above what's the
movie Ben Affleck went him in the six
jerk-offs go to the moon to save the
asteroid again begins on TNT guess what
Tom Segura watches it and those is off
till about 2:30 in the afternoon you
nailed it got it 230 you wake up you go
over your material and you know what
because you're Tom Segura you go to the
gym you do 35 on the elliptical if you
do 25 push-ups and you do curls and you
do stretching and now you feel
tremendous feel great you know what
let's be honest I'm sorry over there
ain't going out for peanuts so you got
an option you can walk downstairs take
an elevator walk down to the corner and
take it over go to a restaurant have ten
people come up to you ask you to
pictures or you should open up the room
service
you will never let the charge in your
mind this is the piece of this is what
you pay for for peace of mind you get
the chicken breasts covered in mushrooms
or whatever the [ __ ] they got that looks
good either in your room you don't even
have to leave your they come you bring
it that's what I do now and that saves
me don't is the most important thing in
your world there's those two shows it's
not going to meet who the uncles got a
museum an hour for me yeah exactly how
many we don't want in my mind I was
playing about goal of jiu-jitsu school I
call every town before I go there oh
there's great guys that have offered me
their gyms I don't want to leave the
hotel
no that time so I'm saying if at all -
isn't that walking distance I don't I
want life to occur around the rod oh
that's how easy when they told us the
comedy Sunday you want to get to the
airport 25 minutes you drink a protein
shake on the way they take your vitamins
once you're there you're pray to God
something's open right yeah you pay
everything you can to cut pretty
expressly have you have you joined clear
yeah the bun is clear and TSA TSA reject
the week but after a while they haven't
gonna be TSA because they know the
[ __ ] dealing with you exactly [ __ ]
you do you know what the thing is if you
do if you're clear and TSA I didn't know
until I sign up
so I sign up for clear and then they go
oh you're pre-checked oh yeah they walk
you to the front so if like now TSA will
have a line they walk you to the front
of the TSA line and then the clear agent
tells the TSA oh yeah
he's he's TSA authority and he just goes
yeah and then they just walk you right
to the [ __ ] secured Mario Lisa a
clear out of LAX now clear listen I put
my two fingers down and I promise'
there's a picture
yeah the first thought I think about his
liver like a doctor
yeah and I always put a 5 in the chicks
hand you do listen I respect who does
that for you who does that for you
I'm he just looked at me the last who
talked both to the chick looked at me
halfway like nobody's ever done done me
and that's just been down one clears
gonna get popular there's gonna be a
bunch of white type people yeah because
they mean I'm gonna give it to you with
the ID because you see walk Schiele like
excuse me it's like nothing you could
ever do in your life
excuse me a bunch of fives
oh yeah no you have to go prepare always
you stop again now hundreds of tens
excuse me excuse me excuse me and dog
somebody could be ready to put their box
on it she's like excuse me she takes the
boxes out for you even helps me jacket
yeah Thank You mr. beer see you next
time you feel like a half a mutt oh man
you just cut through to what people
who've been waiting there please tell
you by the [ __ ]
that is the best when they just look at
you like what
you
last time I left your podcast I
downloaded that had Leonard Saturday
night was Saturday night
[ __ ] whatever it's called a little
skinny song right Saturday night
yeah yeah yeah well that's special yes
and I special because you talked about
that and this [ __ ] is that's a it's a
beautiful song man Tony Bennett I'm
gonna download it - thought I'd drop
dollar job one I know you do
% it's funny we used to have a bar
that's what my mom walked into the bar
she turned the alarm off you turn the
lights on she'd go behind the bar she
put the water on put soap in so the
water would start getting ready
you know she turned the lights on the
back in the first thing she did was turn
the jukebox on and then she would take
corners and if he's caught is what she
did what I did as a kid sometimes she
goes hey take a roll of quarters and put
a red shoe polish on that red nail
polish and that meant those a whole
quarter so that jukebox guy would give
her those quarters back oh okay it's
just like I'm putting my own quarters in
here so you pick up a quarter and it's
1974 and it's got a red [ __ ] nail
polish on it that's one of my mom's
quarters gets Wilder somebody sent me a
picture years ago when I was doing
Beauty to be somebody sent me a preacher
was still out there of those quarters of
those boys [ __ ] crazy if you like
Tony Bennett she liked this song cuz my
dad some would hurt my dad I don't know
what it was
so the first song she always played was
this little Jam so I said Tom deep as
well people with Spanish because people
don't think he'd speak Spanish or no hmm
not not intentionally usually says
somebody would say something and then I
would respond and they go oh like you
know so does it happen that often I mean
it happens but it's not like you know
what'll happen
like you know the guy who comes my house
they start talking to another guy about
work he's doing something on my house
and then as that conversation goes on
I'll jump in and Spanish and then you're
like oh then they kind of like stand up
a little bit straighter like we can't
can't talk behind his back you know that
kind of thing how's it going teaching
your son Spanish it's going great I mean
you know he's - so he he speaks he
speaks he understands English and
Spanish right now he's I mean he says a
few more English words Lee says a lot of
Spanish words that's very cool
yeah it's definitely cool his mercy
speaks Spanish you know but she knows
what the [ __ ] I'm saying yeah she knows
what the [ __ ] says
let's uh and I know she knows what the
[ __ ] I'm saying because she responds to
it in number two I played the same game
at that age when I can you know when
you're when you come from another
country you want to fit it yeah
I didn't want to ease my lease a little
more it's alright we'll cut me a deal in
the house you could speak scratch but
I'm big on speak English
but then I started getting cocky and I'm
like I might even speak in Spanish in
the [ __ ] house are you like me now
[ __ ] so from now on when you ask me for
something I don't know not believe it
so if you want money for sneak is a
little girly kind of ask me in Spanish
cuz she made you keep saying it so I'm
very proud of that thing that she made
me keep speaking it yeah she wouldn't
respond to me unless I spoke Terrance -
Wow but when you got your hell were you
when you got to to Jersey when I was
three maybe two and at that point
definitely only spoke Spanish yeah
yes yes I spoke Spanish a majority of
that you know at the bar they spoke
Spanish there's all space bar pretty
much you know but the people who in
there spoke Spanish you know they spoke
to me in Spanish yeah what are you
thinking thinking about what like what
are your thoughts what language are them
well language a hole in your thoughts he
wants to know what language you think in
like do you think your thoughts in
English or Spanish or both I have a lot
of thoughts I have a lot of worlds I
laugh at you know saying like I have one
of the coldest stories you know I came
from a society that I spoke Spanish up
to about 72 I'm here then from 73 to 75
became a thing called Spanglish great
early spoke Spanglish very funny very
very hilarious the words that they've
chose ya to pick you know what I think
and I was goofing you play with Oh Lucy
Katherine
yes there was a guy when I was growing
up that was not a comedian he was a
bookmaker here jerk off a lot no any
other laugh my mother's bar and he was
there he was one of these guys I got a
job years ago and claim disability and I
thought he paid the doctor percentage to
claim my disability and he collected a
check plus unemployment in those days it
was a scam yeah she got an employment oh
yeah it was gonna dogs every six months
give him an extra three hundred and he
kept you [ __ ] disabled for those days
and the doctor would come to my mother's
bought so it was just a paternal scan
that went on and then he would go back
to work for six months but in the winter
so in the summer they lay him off so
he'd be there taking baseball bats play
anyway he was just one of those the guys
who was a fixture at my mother's ball he
would get there at 10:00 and select the
ball and make some calls or walk to the
corner let he come back he'll that one
said miss either and he would start off
with beers till about lunchtime those
about after lunch and he'd start with
the hard stuff but a 501 he was home
and I grew to love the fact the night
before I did Gotham for New York Comedy
Festival I got together with some
friends at a bar called bar one in West
Bergen my high school teacher boy he was
myself the great teachers bought and a
kid showed up Dean lip-read and he
brought up this guy I lied on because
this kid Dean were pre-thought I known
so long then he went to my mother's bar
and when they were playing wiffle ball
we tried to cut the bat open to put
rocks on the tape enough to make the bat
heavy yeah so you get hit the bar go the
ball would go fall sure and I cut my
thumb right there the scars still right
there might cut it with the color and
I've had it got run into it and he goes
what happens like that I go you know man
I've gone for Facebook looking for his
kids
googoo I feel lucky
I never traced his kids back not one of
them he had two daughters and a gay son
and in the seventies of you were Cuban
and you're a gay son of a son that was
tap old you know yeah I loved him the
same he said some of the funniest
[ __ ] things I ever heard of my wife
in fact I said one of them telling
somebody like we were talking on the bar
one time I must have been 17 and
conversation you know and we were
talking my dicks or something like he he
would always ask me like what's going on
with you would that skinny chick you
[ __ ] me yet like what yeah like you
know like that like he wasn't my uncle
but he was unofficially my own sure and
I really liked him he had kids his or
his wife was called like a egga there's
a different part of Cuba and they cook
tremendous she used to cook and send
food to the bar so we're like a family
but he would always ask him like one
time I used to drive up this girl
so joke my mother crazy so I wish to
lock my door so my mother made him get a
ladder and put it against the side of
the house while I was dry up in New York
and he made him go up but I kind of
heard something of the size of the I
kind of heard something and finally
through the air conditioned I heard the
latter fought him fought he slipped me
broke like his ankle and I go back
Vinnie and I'm what are we doing oh we
were fixing the air conditioner but he
was just a solid dude but yeah but he
told me two things one time one time we
were in conversation and he was told to
meet us what are you crazy or what yes
Oh Heather the [ __ ] suck my dick went
on an ice cube in his mouth yeah I won't
cough Leal empathic and legal and he was
dead serious I was he said was you don't
believe like we were just talking we
were just talking like I'm like 16 it's
not a romantic yeah that was like a [ __ ]
at the bar you know I like hanging out
and he was like with a pet [ __ ] over
there and he liked it all something like
they ever tell you the story about the
time the facts I might think one ice
cube no you did not say that to me
and you make somebody is it the secret
of his mouth was called the felt
tremendous and I just [ __ ] yeah he
goes oh is the and I woke up I mailed my
mother took me longer to spider free
another time I had already I was about
18 and I was bartending I was still in
high school and I would bartend one
afternoon shift and hell all my friends
were there we were all smoking dope and
drinking and he like I said he would
hang out every day till 5:00 taught us
ignore and like a week before that my
friends got mine he was talking about
smoking dope they wrote the big bamboo
and they got him [ __ ] up he was
another table just laying there and the
next day he called me is like what was
in there he just felt a little walking
home I mean he he was just a funny dude
yeah so I had a friend called damn Ringo
who was a bodybuilder steroid [ __ ]
not cocaine solid dude it's a solid you
were loves Tom Segura you know my I hang
out with his cousin because though he
says you know what's crazy Coco right
now dad would be in California with you
and know that for a fact and by now he
was my three people you have been my
personal Mike Tyson Darren didn't [ __ ]
around especially after a he went that
white powder came around he became was
he not around anyone no he died before
he died he'd gotten arrested for
attempted murder I knew it I knew him
all my life
he was my brother ahead but he saw his
mother got cancer and died in front of
her he never recovered from that Tom
Segura when you see your mom one day
she's healthy
the next thing you know you gotta pick
her up and put him in the bathtub that
affects you a certain way and he already
had that gotten divorced that's what I
wasn't divorced triggered it and the mom
with the cancer put the [ __ ] and
Haiti this was it this was the answer
there was no other answer was no let's
hold hands and say a prayer yeah
the answer was let's go slow on the
[ __ ] table and then he added
Decker to a [ __ ] mix oh and now the
juice to contest the cocaine the whole
thing as an interesting stew
that the guy almost got me one night and
I grew up with this dude let's just say
his name was Tommy and would that I
asked the guy cuz I knew he was a
cokehead
[Music]
he goes yeah what do you want I don't
want like a G bonus on your nose give me
on your bus I said you got a no there's
no I gotta call the guy who will call
the guy you don't know
you gotta call the guy you gotta give me
the money and I bought side away from
you know what Tom Segura I know you're a
long time
yeah I'm not just giving a yardstick all
the do this one for ten minutes
I finally act I said forget about it I
look like I owe you a long time if you
were gonna beat me just telling me well
a year later I hear the score same thing
pay that to my friend ragga he took the
money
raiga let me play Ringo went to his
house the next morning not gonna door
you know but you don't people have glass
squares by the door
yeah the curtains in front of ya Rhaego
just put his hand through one open the
door limb and he ran and daran daran
punched him he went through the table to
do the table down pull the leg and
started hitting him in the head with it
cops came down and got arrested for
attempted murder he was on a bail he
died that's the true story dad was ready
to start [ __ ] I saw him picked up a
do one time and throw him over a fence
her father the VFW
another time me and him couldn't get
coke there was a [ __ ] snow storm
I told leave the story we couldn't get
cocaine and we were sitting to the bar
called Joel berries and this is the bar
yeah we're facing this way that's what
the TV is that's where the pool table is
but there's a good window here and me
and him have our drinks here and we're
looking out the window at the [ __ ]
six inches of snow and how cause all
right now and we're praying plans Cody
lava get here
there was no Coke on Thursday because of
the blizzard there's no Coke on Friday
because of the blizzard and now there's
saddling there's still not come to
George Washington Bridge is closed jack
unless you got a canoe and you're not
getting into the city so we have a one
guy who kept saying man I don't know my
car I get stuck this tree free the snow
out there couldn't even get the
newspaper in those days but I mean this
guy said yeah I told him I told lujah I
thought christ-killers was so left and
he's feeling better that we looked and
this a guy minding his business
cross-country skiing like when sigh whoa
hohoho like like this in New Jersey
this is Bergen like that like he wanted
goes here he goes a mountain yeah play
this guy's out there like this is lucky
day he's doing exercise now I'd all
about cross-country skiing because I was
living in Colorado for a while yeah and
people would do it there were people who
were like [ __ ] half [ __ ] maybe
you go down a hill now you want to
[ __ ] pull yourself here's this poor
bastard I'll never forget this
pulling himself down the [ __ ] burger
light Avenue Bergen when is like
Broadway in [ __ ] New York City yeah
but there's no traffic but this guy is
going down
Darren looks at the sky and he goes look
at this [ __ ] guy and he goes he looks
at me to us let's just [ __ ] him up and
what next thing though I he just pushed
me and he started chasing the guy down
of their forgiveness the guy's pulled
himself like you know SiC him like a car
his day song yeah and Diaries just
tackled them just started hitting them
with the skis it was crazy and I still
like aided this route they kicking him
it was like a scene from The Sopranos
yeah we dragged it I had no idea what
the [ __ ] was no nothing
we will all [ __ ] pissed past and then
we brought it and we put them over the
VFW fence and we threw the skis back
then he's back there moaning groaning
we'll like [ __ ] you
nobody skis upbringing like that though
we went a pack of the board guess who
shows up the coke dealer the coke dealer
shows up oh my god oh my god everybody's
[ __ ] pie and blow Herbies order in
doubles will flock it's snowing will
having a great time oh my god and all
sudden it's a quarter to three and
there's police cars everywhere and we
look at things you go home after after
doing that three three and the bus cause
it's 10:00 to 3:00 we're all [ __ ]
gizelle yeah the whole exists 20 people
at the bar sixteen of them their jaws
are going yeah tell them the stories
about the war and God knows what else
also you like what the [ __ ] everybody
please come out with your hands up or
heads up like what we hide the cook but
I know all the cops I see one of the
Cowboys I know that if I shake his hand
and put some minute I might just be able
to slip over beside like a little extra
business weapons in my hand
well I saw Bob present hey what's up I
put it on yeah and just keep on dying
he's okay with me and he walked me up as
I'm walking away I'm looking at police
car there was a guy we threw over the
fence check was on the back of a police
car ain't just trembling right
they got blankets on them they don't
like a guy with a heater on in these
[ __ ] classic Jesus Christ you [ __ ]
psychos what a great [ __ ] night that
was yeah that was a crazy bra guy
we will we will have together that night
I will have delivered some friends we
brought it up that was about two weeks
after we reimburse those dorms that yeah
yeah and that was about two weeks after
we were having a party there the Samhain
Amen oh the owner of the club dues Joel
marries Joe and Mary were both dead
the guys name was I forget what his name
was it really doesn't matter for the
story but in real I think I was a long
shot yeah the guy was a mob loan shark
was he in the mob I did not say that I
said he was a mob loan shark how do I
know because he to borrow money from him
yeah little banks he would get you a
check but you would have to catch her in
a certain bank and that's how he got his
percentage he was way ahead of the game
what and this is 80 [ __ ] - so don't
come to me with no [ __ ] stories yet
nah worth nothing off you know he was
drinking
[ __ ] it was a Saturday night back
again you know it would be ruled [ __ ]
blow who's not even Gorilla Biscuits and
there's he a [ __ ] cop came and then
the cover count
he's like hey man something like some
violation or whatever the donors name
was George but that was the borrower's
name joy he was a little stocky guy you
could tell that if you were gonna have a
problem this is not the type of guy you
he was a barback bro yeah he never
worked behind the bar he always sat at
the bar he bought you drinks
you know he spoke to you he was a
gentleman but he watched that register
and that night this cop came in talking
[ __ ] and he goes into me a favor and me
show me a bit broke the bar was 50 deep
with all of us in there snorting blow
and God knows and he asked a cop and for
everybody that like [ __ ] 2:00 in the
morning
we see the badging and the compliment
cop was like all jovial bother with some
other guy is back up
he showed attempt in George's are
splitting the guys bad she goes do me a
favor
you call your local whatever you tell
him you came in in George spit in your
beds now get the [ __ ] out of my bar that
bar [ __ ] froze Jack that's what we
knew and I knew I was dead because I
hold him like [ __ ] 8000 because I kept
borrowing from him I would tell him Tom
Segura needs 800 please embarrassed
Arashi his tongue good for it time to
smile and I know Tom 20 years all right
how much they can't pay me every break
you'll pay 75 a week Tom you didn't even
know you had borrowed the money what you
would know that I would pay him under
your name [ __ ]
until finally I haven't just bail on
mother everybody she knows was crazy so
they don't get what he come after you
he never came after me but when I left
the Colorado I left like 10 months and
when I went back I went back that was my
high school ball I was I went back one
night I went to the side door and my
friends a place you can pool I was with
my buddy stinky who also hold him money
and I'll never forget we'd like to the
side glass and my friends look something
that like it's joy and then look at
everything and I'm liking it
his joy cheer and my friends like what
and then one finally with my friend I
was doing was called by a boy I go to
George here and also here
no George is up here I look up me and
stinky and George is listening to the
wind laters how you boys doing it's been
a while I go yeah we wanted to see he
goes give me 10 minutes I'll be right
down
alright we [ __ ] got in that car we
took off
and never so [ __ ] Georgia get you
inside
oh my god today it's not Joe Mary's no
more guess what it is why it's Jose and
Maria's Mexicans took it over you know
saying Christ men your story give me
anxiety they're so vivid that's not
crazy that was a crazy [ __ ] bar bro
you know they was serving us only were
16 I'm Bert Bertman half on Bergen wine
Avenue they were all 80 Street some
knife tip up there listen bro we would
go up there juni think about how old do
you ten of us that we're cool
you could whup then drink I'm here man
like you couldn't tell like everybody
like Tom yes there's certain people you
can try can't bring up that this is us
you we go we got a couple months of the
end we get potato chips li bar potato
chips not wise there was no lays there
was bar potato chips and we get Frank's
hot sauce and getting that gonna lay it
out and eat potato chips and shoot pool
till six like we were tough guys you
know what that feels like when you're
sixteen oh yeah
you have any idea what kind of person
you would be no no drugs Lee how
different would you be today if every
day after school you went to a bar shot
pool had three or four beers a bag of
chips and went home and your mom's like
how is studying you're like very
differently cyan let me explain it to
you
what I'm looking what you didn't do that
no no no I did a couple times I spent
the only sorrow I have is that
immediately cyan when I was 16 because
right now as sad as this is we were the
wait six other parents two doors down
from that bar John marriage all right a
black six blocks to the south of it was
the original my loyalty
don't cook tonight called chicken
delight mm-hmm they will my that's how I
became an American hot dogs McDonald's
and chicken though but up to corner next
to doors next to that bar was something
else it was like chicken delightful
uh-huh and it was owned by Ritchie
Seidel little part-time bookie his kid
it was [ __ ] we were kids but they
used to get mad or off they used to get
mad a lot of 1980 and they used to have
time to his bicycle and make him fly off
his roof it was hysterical and every
week and he'd have a different
babysitter and if he had ten
babysitter's I sucked for their titties
because that's where he went the white
side I live and [ __ ] eleven o'clock
hysterical Thompson what would you do at
least I had if he was if he minimus you
know I would leave at 10 o'clock every
night like clockwork of you where Joel
marries the manager of the chicken place
would come over with two buckets of
whatever chicken they have left over
from the day and they just made the
chicken at six Lisa for two hours you
would just sit there and eat fried
chicken and drink [ __ ] mugs a
Heineken for 65 cents a month away how
how would you be you'd be that bar with
them what's the show you fell in love
with about Boston
cheers Cheers that's you oh yeah they
used to give you for free at this bar
Joel Mary for free and if you walked in
while it was the bartender and for free
there was a circle and on that dish
she's like when you go to Subway and
like yeah the dishes of sandwiches for
parties none of this was a circle like
that but it was white bread with ham and
Swiss cheese with a little bit of mayo
maybe a nice piece of tomato and they
would put them all they'd be like a
thousand of these things under a
container and if you were drinking you
were allowed to pick up to contain
anyone and put one back like a thing
like a normal American
yeah that's all normal human being
does oh my god me and my buddies would
destroy those things we would smoke dope
Kojo marries or the two mugs of beer a
baguette or chip we just eat every chip
on the rack in those days that have
chips on the rack we just take every bag
of chips and he every [ __ ] Sam we did
that a 16 they were serving us Jesus
Christ man sounds like fun it's not that
what if I'm it's just thinking of what
how different society was and people do
it Tom so there were people knowing how
it dude
it was different even when I was a
teenager we would we would go into bars
you know like we would drink people
would serve you at their homes at their
bucket they if you if they knew you
weren't one of those just [ __ ] off kids
like you know it's just you weren't a
jerk off people that I knew would serve
you in high school and not in like a oh
my god you get away with something way
they were just like you can handle
yourself you're fine they give you a
drink I had a couple pants friends of
parents that were crazy and it was cold
particular have told me you can do
whatever you want my house just don't
ever drink in my house we told you that
tell our friends of parents
oh one in particular said you come over
my house you're gonna sleep here I just
don't ever want you drinking in my house
I never drink with you I don't wanna you
know and it was cool yeah it was cool
I thought he drank and I drank I'm still
friends with oh I got you okay
did you mean like as a kid they would
the parents will tell you that yeah I
don't like it you know like I won't
drink I'm funny mercy yeah I don't know
if all Mouse really know from my
perspective I know what it did to me
seeing my know the freedom it gives you
your parents are your heroes and so
whatever once they see you heroes
drinkin go get a drink
yeah once they see you smoking a
cigarette okay to smoke your parents a
hero's yeah yeah I never thought of it
like that actually if they see you're
doing coke what are the chances that
they're gonna do coke that's probably a
lot higher now that's how you careful
with weed then and over now very careful
and that's why I know that within the
stuff she watches she watches as she
moves around the house like a rough
snake gilliam to see it comin you gotta
be very careful with it you keep like in
a private like locked stash that kind of
thing
I got hidden somewhere hidden somewhere
yeah
he goes she opens it she can't see it
you know where we headed I just rip out
one day when she learns back that's weed
tolerance Ben she'll lose her mind right
do you ever know you never really know
its head level with that first you know
how you approach things as a parent and
you want the best for your kid comes to
you you know what you get to do blow or
pill of course you want the best you
know you want them you know you look at
them first you say you want a healthy
child then you want a child that fits
into society you know who his grandma
school years in high school I don't need
him to be a high school star or anything
I'll take the [ __ ] kid to your family
hell mean anything I mean it would be
nice to have [ __ ] some linebacker
over at Penn State as well yeah see this
Maxim [ __ ]
that's like some date then you little CK
looking askew really take your dick
[ __ ] Penn State Dean and say here's
one for Joe Paterno and as cousin what
was the cousin's name - kuklinski what's
the cousin we talked about that the
football coach at Penn Stater - 11 years
and dusky Sandusky like a crazy man
it's nuts
it's good to see you always I was gonna
say you were a breath of fresh air it's
nice to see you doing well you know your
wife is a [ __ ] that kind as usual I
haven't seen the channel I'm excited
dude we're gonna have so much fun
tomorrow man you're so happy you're
coming on the economy's [ __ ] second I
don't know what's a special coming out
there it's coming out January 12th so
this is your fourth left foot special
third you're like [ __ ] Johnny Netflix
I don't know man I'm not the super happy
they let me do another one there
honestly I'm just happy so then you way
you wanted to breathe this is you know
we were talking about tour before and
and the efforts of being a feature act
that I had like yeah you know you want
people to leave there and though they
paid money I don't want to take a chance
it's like the people well let's go out
to dinner at 6:00 what and do what talk
to you about what for an hour right then
they always bring the goofy friends so
how is it hanging that when I listen on
your business right
why do you buy your gear how is it
hanging out with Ari your [ __ ] food
if you're gonna take me out to dinner
ask me a thousand questions yeah I'm not
gonna doing that's why before showtime
I don't want to see nobody there reminds
me no idea what you bet you said black
people eat to talk but I go what are you
sitting
go front to eat to talk and you said if
somebody [ __ ] talks while I'm eating
I'm gonna [ __ ] stab them in the neck
but you had a whole rant I don't know if
you if you even remember saying this a
whole rant about eating to talk a
[ __ ] crazy things that trend you know
you know what's going on I can't believe
we take a loo years off yeah middle
level [ __ ] Savage like yourself take
it off I'm scared
I can't why here about what New Year's
why were you doing it I'm not if I did
Louise it would be the 80 o'clock show
at the ice house in the small room small
intimate yeah walk through the heart
end-of-the-year review we saw at playing
the drums don't you try to do that
anyways I'm taking a family away are you
out there
okay throw a nice beach resort up north
good for you good for the kids you come
back Monday morning the first inside
[ __ ] the Mad Max like the apocalypse
yeah
there's nobody on the 101 we go chase a
[ __ ] nickel yeah nights that I've
chased you know I was thinking about
that
when you first start out me you know you
met you MC for a while then you start
milling and you start hearing about all
this money we're gonna be paying on New
Year's yeah that's the big thing that I
could look you in the face both these
and pay the honest or not true I never
got paid for big money on
every [ __ ] Club Robin oh I got [ __ ]
on a bunch of new your stuff but you did
like the these stories about what New
Year's was like is like it was such
that's the hottest rumor you know but
like it there is some truth to it
but people would be like you know you
just hear like someone's getting like 10
grand do someone you like what they're
like yeah New Year's [ __ ] really pops
off I remember I meddled once on New
Year's we still did five or six shows
but instead of $100 a show they gave me
150 a show for the week because of New
Year's and I thought that was crazy
money like at the time I'll say wait
what I'm not gonna get 600 I'm gonna get
like 1,100 and they're like yeah I go
like holy [ __ ] this is so much money
like I really thought that was a crazy
amount of money that was hitting an
extra three hundred dollars or something
and then a few years later I remember I
did a New Year's gig where the money was
like just marginally more and I and I
looked at the ticket price and they're
charging like eighty-five dollars to go
to some of these New Year's Eve shows
and I tried to get you know a little
more money I think they kicked it up
like another 250 dollars or something
but if you can get you can still make
crazy you can make crazy much Sarah and
I robbed me two years in a row who ever
forget that Cyril I she used to book the
Buffalo yeah the Buffalo funnybone in
connection with the Miami improv to get
into Miami you have a Kshatriya into
Buffalo in January first
oh you she didn't like you if you
weren't part of the agency well let's
say Joe Rogan recommended you yeah she
told him Buffalo for us I got to we fear
time Buffalo yeah yeah Miami
you know the Buffalo for us January 8th
to the 12th you'll be a feature of bingo
to clowns and then the following we be
one in Miami and you got a middle for
the hypnotist and you're like oh my god
I'm quitting this [ __ ] yeah and then she
robbed me a few times I always got
robbed rogon took a me all those years
feel only gave me a little bit extra
listen this is what I feel about notice
nobody as long as I can with you some
weight to thanks guys
I like making money I try to make money
I've been doing this for 27 years I
deserve to make money
ya ain't [ __ ] for a lot of years I think
I robbed for a lot of years and my
crying no it made me a comic I am sorry
but you look what the clubs charge they
want to charge some [ __ ] piece of
salmon that they got from Katrina left
over some [ __ ] guy bought 20 mm or
will you [ __ ] salmon you know crab
legs they want to give you all this [ __ ]
and hype it up and pay the comic and you
know what the other day it's just a
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] show and if you get
caught up in the food and the whole
thing and here's a guy like me telling
you right now I'd rather you come see me
January 22nd someone yeah and it's a lot
easier it's a lot painful for you you're
gonna sit next to people for Late Show
that I haven't had a drink yeah it's six
months I got puke on your dress I've
seen [ __ ] on New Year's Eve laying the
NOI
I was excited yeah I bombed one time my
New Year's in Miami exactly but that was
a rough room and
one shell but both on the flames Salazar
but I mean death of a thousand dicks
tell your voice bottle never know this
is one of the many this oh wait one
another thing I hate about this New
Year's pricing is that the last one I
did was at a club and I think some of
the things were actually a hundred
dollars for like the fool yeah you know
but usually think the sucks is that
people hit you up and they go you charge
$100 to see you and you have to explain
to them that you know yeah it's like
they only give you a bottle of champagne
that something could be a headache for
three days yeah I don't like million
rapes they got from the dory ager and
you couldn't explain that to everybody
not everybody was saying that and you
try to be fair in your mind and you go
you know what I would love to do a New
Year's show like I said it's a Sunday
night into Monday I would really
consider an eight o'clock show 200
people tops I would love it if they were
able to smoke reefer in there yeah and a
drink you know and the low intermission
three comics you're out there at 9:30
yeah listen you know what no pictures
get the [ __ ] out it's gonna be low end
go take pictures for three years and
jump up and down no blow just real
comedy friends yeah that want to watch a
comedy show that's why I liked it though
but the winning in that time by action
sure I like your idea of doing the annex
the Ice House that's it
eight o'clock everybody's home by 9:30
that's a great way to do it I don't want
a toast yeah I don't want you on
@midnight
I really don't want you wanted midnight
I really don't want you driving at 1:00
a.m.
for stupidity unless is Jesus talking
why you had a [ __ ] New Year's Eve
stamp yeah it's like 10:30 you should be
home 10:30 nice take smoke and um but
get a package I don't give a [ __ ] you
get a heroin as long as you're home by
10:30 she
I don't give a [ __ ] what you do
maybe but every minute you stay out over
ten thirty
you get an average you get hit in the
head with a stick ya get Buster for
something who don't do this who's
drinking and driving who know who's not
puking and once you've done all those
who he is yeah you're like you know what
this is the last on don't ya know it I
like your idea of doing it in a small
room that's enough people like yeah
let's do the will trail we'll do eight
o'clock ship you listened then you find
out the ten o'clock show yeah now I'll
be down there Donna o'clock and that's
too late no you know what this is dumb
as this sounds I got family now guess
what I'm gonna get grapes I'm gonna get
the bottle of wine my friend sending me
that Cuban peanut brittle
yeah I got family now let's toast a
family I need the money I gotta be out
there fighting like an animal
do you know where well ya know a new one
then the next day we went like you're
for the hair for slow and I was stuck at
the airport [ __ ] hotel for today leave
me alone it hugs all the weeks to work
and with you and that Ben is not going
nowhere and people don't get offended
haven't been doing new here's one year
somewhere that's a high level Club and
they couldn't get the mail on top you
know what that's like what the computer
goes down only is evilly and people want
inflamed in Yelm instead they get a
piece of salmon that looks like
Harlequin huh it looks like it's ten
years old and now you gotta go up
there's the feature I can be funny cool
and while you're on stage they go no I
ordered it medium rare you know what
that feels like
hallelujah and you're getting [ __ ]
600 for a week for eight shows if that's
what I got 600 for a [ __ ] show so I
paid my dues on New Year's I cut my
teeth on three years god bless the
people who offered me work this year on
New Year's that's my offer and I'm
sticking to it it's too late now now I'm
leaving on Sal
where's the what's there where's your
worst Bob do you know which one it is
she just next there was a period I was
just Bob really all the time
I wanted a bombing Hanks to call clubs
at a time and call it a bomb scale it
was get ready cuz I'm gonna bump that I
know no well when you're a comic in the
beginning you have to buy you have to
borrow you have to bomb you have to bomb
and you have to bomb and you have to
bomb and you have to keep bombing and
the situation's worsen and it's just
like any other [ __ ] situation that
you get yourself into that has high
stakes later on yeah down in the future
if you stick with any of these things
any of these dumb things that you become
a special yeah and doing you have to pay
your [ __ ] dues
one way or another I don't know what
they are but I can't describe calming
for you you have to live it I love the
people who call you know hey didn't you
say it took you five years to feature
yeah it took me nine years you [ __ ]
[ __ ] and you sit there and go watch
the beat this guy gets on the road yeah
this guy's gonna get the motive so many
times that easily quit right pick up the
mo totally they go out of his features
and after the first night the MCS eat
their lunch bro and the guy ain't got 22
minutes I saw he dig people people
change a lot like yes yes oh no guys
it's bro I know a dude that star there's
a [ __ ] Atlanta on Wednesday and my
Saturday he was the house he was M
saying I went on you know I swear to my
mother's grave that's a whole [ __ ]
story dawg I got demoted before the show
once so like not even due to the show no
you did that yeah I showed up and they
were like well actually no I got the
email that said hey we booked you two
middle but you're gonna MC and I was
like okay and then
the next email said actually you just
off the show so they they emailed me
twice to let me know that I was demoted
like the day of the show I'm thinking
I'm gonna feature for a weekend and like
no you're gonna emcee for a weekend and
actually you're not gonna do but I got
just kicked off the show but I was I did
a show I did a weekend one time where I
was the emcee and they made the middle
and I switch they demoted the will you
drooled bad what was she doing that good
no no the other way around the middle I
was I'm seeing and they told me the
middle in the middle to emcee the the
middle was doing badly and I was having
good sets so they switched us okay one
time that was that was brutal to [ __ ]
witness men brutal it's embarrassing it
is yeah
it's really embarrassing one time I did
so good a feature spot in a Florida tell
they make the comic quit I had one Jesus
through the glasses he was so messed
because he at that time I was at the
store and I was doing the 12:45 spot
following Paul Mooney every night and I
had 20 that would bury him then first 20
what really is I was at the store you
have to follow dice yeah what are you
gonna do you know followed I see if you
go on that stage you go let's keep it on
four dice what I'm gonna do on the dial
you know I came up here you die and
after you take ten alone you go okay I'm
not gonna surrender right off the bat
yeah I'm gonna give him what he deserves
and I'm gonna attack these [ __ ]
and everything I got yeah and that's
where you learn that strategy that's why
I love people don't dog I couldn't
follow him because you died before you
bring down on stage don't give him the
limelight bank accounts a girl for
coming on stage and attack them like a
[ __ ] pit bull for four minutes until
they forget who the [ __ ] Thompson or
even was don't forget if you attack them
hard yeah the fur
then it's time to girl don't even exist
they won't remember me a little till the
way out over him he was funny too and
you're like nah because you attacked
them I used to lose the war in my head
as a young comic yeah oh I can't follow
that clean stuff look at all those
people with white hair in the audience
yeah it's not so I eliminated that
factor I don't want to say the audience
I don't give a [ __ ] who they are yeah I
just cut their go out then do your
material because once you start catering
and bantering that's where you learn to
bomb well then that Chinese there yeah
then that day goes this can you smell my
feet now there he goes this set see you
know like if you go I have a bunch of
Chinese people indoor I said about the
guy I rear-ended that was Chinese there
goes that eight-minute Ben if you don't
do that bit you just lost him yeah
totally right do that bit with all the
confidence in the world that you have do
that bit like if you were in front of 20
white people in fact I want you to turn
to them as you do that bit because the
more confidence you show the more
they're gonna laugh their ass off
because they're Chinese they know they
can't drive maybe they have a hard time
walking around the airport they all
stopped at the door at the airport even
though you're given a rush they get the
a gate yeah they all stop and look
around like it's Oh what the [ __ ] you
look at that move move the [ __ ] this is
the enter exit and they want to sit
there and look around and find this was
look at the lighting in here this is a
great journey yeah this is a great
journey this has been a great journey
for gallic me it's been a great journey
for yelling you definitely what made you
get on stage I'm when you're
college-educated nice I mean I just I
always wanted to perform in this truth I
just wanted to be in comedy I didn't
think it was gonna be stand-up I really
thought I was gonna be like a comedic
actor you know like be on TV be in
movies like that was the the thought for
me
are you still done TV and movies I mean
I don't know I you know a couple lines
here and they were interested in the
recurring show
and taking you off the road for six
weeks and just focusing on something two
days a week like that's all I ever want
that be great man this is what I don't
want to be number one I don't want to be
a joy deer show yeah I want Tom Segura
to have his on the show and I'm the guy
that comes in every three up as opposed
to breaking balls yeah for five minutes
that he loves Joey yeah I love Joey
Christine but everyone someone him to
the Mobius strip yelling different you
know yeah that's all I wanted to do yeah
that's it the neighbor the garbage man
yep for sure I grew up watching The
Times and all those type of shows they
were character driven and it was a guy
that came one every two weeks and you
were yearned for him but then it evolved
into your face to save the shell not
gonna steal the show
Tom didn't Christine yeah I'm gonna add
flavor one week I'm saying something
with the kids check whatever and you
stay home you focus on that need some
[ __ ] one of brothers food right why
fight yourself and go on the [ __ ]
readers work on this set for a couple of
days it's not the same Willy on the road
but you focus on that and you get some
more experiences to write off you know
it's always something yeah the last five
years like I said I got caught up I
always loved going on the road my
[ __ ] again I loved one of the road
for five weeks at a time by the third
week you just destroying more hipsters
yeah
you're just destroying them you know you
you warm up on Thursday night and Friday
and Saturday you get your beat Athiya
and you're just leveling I'm not you
learn how to level when you take a
little bit and put it in between this
bit yeah and middle in here and live
this one here and next thing you know
yeah it's a great [ __ ] feeling but
all the society that is [ __ ] I've
already done the eight week runs and the
six-week runs and the ten week runs and
now I was down to the last year and a
half
- the two weeks of mud runs and even
that's getting to me a little bit
it's burn on you yeah because sometimes
you get that four out of five week thing
yeah yeah so you know it's - a month
right yeah yeah I know exactly that
that's a slick agent move - they're like
yeah you're just gonna work you're good
at two weeks every month so you do the
last week so this one month and the
first two weeks the next month you'll I
got no more and for that [ __ ] don't move
now I need a time she's growing yeah you
know you like being home - you're a good
in town guy you like it it's a good
feeling - by the way I'm not saying it
in a negative way I'm saying tell you
something man
you live in Los Angeles you've moved to
Los Angeles for a reason come to me with
whatever reason you may have you moved
here for a central reason a square root
as they say in matter that square root
is to walk out of here something
somebody something a writer a casting
guy whatever the [ __ ] you do if you live
in Los Angeles wherever the [ __ ] you
live guess what I'm only gonna meetings
I don't want to be involved what is
involved in me that I gotta be [ __ ]
Jack Bruce and I gotta be Harvey
Weinstein
it means that this Tulio's don't tell go
busy there's not three rows and three
paths 3 rows 10 movies
that's Utah I promise ago is intelligent
yeah it's looking a long time same thing
with all this programming on Netflix
Hulu original programming iTunes Amazon
has original programming not to mention
the four networks there's not six
episodes of you you don't see yourself
I'm not saying yeah Tom Segura the
countess same time so give it a funny
kind of surgery will ya
you'll do this six episodes for you
somewhere for sure man I'm sorry so that
would be ten weeks off the road you
wouldn't be making the same money but it
would throw you off it'd give you a
little bit more insight and you wouldn't
just feel like a piece of meat that
you're out there constantly all these
agencies were with they just don't have
one floor they have five or six floors
yeah like oh I know I'm not involved in
five or six operations but there's free
allows for us I could help you with yeah
and I want everybody involved instead of
like I told you a lily story they game
the TV show and UTA said really crazy so
waiting you gonna pay him after the
executive producer and after the actor
and the creator you're gonna give them
one hundred fifty thousand that's what
not pocket which ten points a lot of net
that was like what 15 yeah but if you
put him on the road like a [ __ ]
hooker yeah farther inside they love
like it's getting hot in here yeah I'll
take off all your clothes me throw water
rather than him as a fool [ __ ] the st.
lous [ __ ] bother you jump up and down
they [ __ ] well they [ __ ] that 250
and their t-shirts and merchandise and
Ellie gives you a hug and kiss so that's
a half a mil weekend that's [ __ ]
fifty thousand Commission what do you
want you want fifteen thousand fifty
thousand dollar Commission yeah what do
you want guys what do you want the best
for your client but sometimes you have
to control that a little more and go the
roles are here and when you do get the
audition you have to prepare you know I
can't see anyone
those days are gonna those days are
going in and using the paper part time I
got well then go to the audition oh they
really want like throw that one in last
week for the mick mm-hmm I was all
booked Jack completely I brought it then
I have a base I always bring them in
there just to have a starting point did
you go out for the Royal bird yeah yeah
Portobello yeah yeah were you there -
yeah yeah everybody was there I really
was that for Brian for saying I saw two
guys for Sopranos who was there with you
were there who was there
Oh Adam Ferrara right that's his name of
his name Wow and John Daly I thinks his
name like the golfer and then who else
was there a couple of guys but those
those two guys were sure Julie Ashton
she cast yeah oh she cast me in for
pilots she's great three TV shows I mean
she's really great for you but she's I
think she's especially quality one time
at a quarter to six and so oh no you can
do with this favorite as a pilot quoi my
PD blue 2069 it streamlines it's a
co-star if it gets picked up it's
recurring cuz to lose paper got in the
corner can you do it can you be a fox
and a half hour [ __ ] yeah she took care
me pay me like so I had a nice lines too
I was out of there by 11 o'clock at
night I read the pilot that had no
chance and how I get him picked up there
was a network at a man that man I'd like
to do a couple movies a year something
lovelies you've got a lot of it though
man it's impressive you know my MDB is
rockin I can't even watch man I'm saying
like it's impressive man I look at my DB
every six months and I squirrel and I
cannot believe that I could truly look
in the eye and like totally this and the
people before I thought I would be an
extra one time on the TV show really
when I got here there was a girl if
she's still here maybe doing comedy but
she was doing extra work but she was
telling me how much one she was doing
she was doing extra sag work on friends
so the [ __ ] would have [ __ ] with her
friends at home she would put certain
objects on this set while the people
weren't watching you know so yeah lets
you put this weed thing in the chair and
they would tape with the wheat that way
then she'd go take it and hopefully it
would make the cut like she was having
so much fun
she's loving I gotta and there was a guy
at the store that was very creepy and
you've always come up to Ringo you
they were shooting the Titanic in
Ensenada I'm at the time I think if
Ensenada don't [ __ ] yell at me people
which was events or nada that was
shooting the Titanic somewhere from San
Diego you know like I don't from San
Diego and every day to a little hiatus
and this guy scan was he took a Polaroid
of it you paid him 50 bucks and then you
went down this but I went like a slave
and they gave you $50 for the day if he
made it but I didn't know a guy the guy
that opens the elevator
he was an extra dog you know this first
surge or check was probably a velvet
what you don't want to know what like 30
G's no oh my god for opening the door
the elevator
that's flooding downstairs I just saw
him about a month ago he stood here he's
a commercial guy and he he had a line or
he just yeah well he tell us that
running here and he's all scared as [ __ ]
she comes in that's flooding and he
opens the gate he closes it he pushes
the button he has like a liner to his
first check put him right in an
apartment got a little car it's not a
coke commercial with a baffle and Diet
Coke that was international he's a
commercial fact yeah did your um your
resume for acting is nuts because I I
wasn't getting any love as a comic there
was no zero or that is dessert ready
let's be honest it must be strictly
honest nobody was touching me but
theatrical agents were styling me in
commercial people I would walk into any
mid-level agency and get [ __ ] a sign
within minutes in those days it was the
big ones that would not touch me they
would [ __ ] him take my envelope and put
me through hell which is what I needed
at the time I needed a but Gersh
theatrically is a character agent yeah
somebody who sent out characters then I
did get with the best character comedy
guy but by that time he lost it at that
time but I was with a chick for a while
that was very good
her name is Nancy Hoff and I was turned
upon to her by a really good manager
she's not anymore
are you just not where I work you know
but we both moved on but she was
somebody that I met with when I was
looking for agents my manager took me
like three different agencies where they
offered you water as [ __ ] and they
validated your parking at the time
unless you lived here in like 98 mm you
remember
I would mm-hmm going up I'll think about
going up yeah
past the what's the [ __ ] the hardrock
place the rock place over there with war
terror used to work
it's a highly Lola Brer I don't know how
you got on the 101 door to anybody you
know you go north on Highland okay if
yeah that's that place the Disney
Concert Hall yeah it [ __ ] that Hollywood
and Highland thing there yeah but if you
would make that first turn there was a
building there was decapitated it looked
like it was about to go down okay
Wow so this agent Christmas week he goes
Joe and we gotta get you a pilot my
agent that I had that was also very good
a black lady my first agent was called
the coloring book how's the name of the
they were on the Warner Brothers lot and
they were black and the one chick was a
badass agent and the old was an attorney
that probably got me a pilot they closed
a nice deal for me they were badass
[ __ ] but her and her husband broke up
so they left me out there like a hot
potato so my agent he showcased me
I got a some interest from CAA at the
time but they were like he's good
character actor but we don't want to
comedic Lee at all like at all
I believe in tell us he's a comic he's
terrible so I'll never forget I met with
this big dude was still around I forget
what his name was all those places where
they offered you water and [ __ ] like
10:30
yeah and then that one we met with this
other guy hawlucha Boulevard I stir all
over the building
the guy was a greasy [ __ ] just telling
me all types of lies you ever sit across
from those guys yeah and cigar you know
what before you came in here I looked at
yeah uh I saw something oh yeah but I
called Tarantino I told Terry
well it's counted in quit quit and these
guys will tell you there's people they
will [ __ ] them tell you this like I just
got off the phone with quite them we're
really interested in you getting this
role and you're sitting it coming in
your pants like that because you gonna
listen to Daddy and pick up 250 this
week and your plane ticket allows
because you have to sit in the back next
to escaped convicts from some fight oh
my god Lee you have no idea what those
dreams are like it's the dude I remember
one guy one time I was like hey I think
I have this thing like you all you have
to do this is like early on I'm like
host this event like a live event in San
Diego pays like two grand would you be
interested in that I was like why and
this is and then he goes do you have a
media kit I don't even know what the
[ __ ] that was man so I started to like
make [ __ ] not knowing how to do it
type up in format documents and then I
sent it to him and he was I was like you
get it he goes yeah yeah I'll hit you
right back
and then those the guys that like those
guys that make big promises like just
never hit you back so you just wait on
that call I don't agree the beginning is
horrible it's horrible
it's the worst man a pain when you send
them the stuff and they give you the
dates then the dates come and they go
with somebody else and you're like what
the [ __ ] and you really need the [ __ ]
rent money but time you will fortunate
you took what you had you're a funny
[ __ ] guy you know
you're the real deal dog thanks buddy
and that's why the way you want to lay
you were this bird that's a TV show that
I'm watching this hold up let me give
shoutouts when you do that topic yeah
you know [ __ ] down Harmon and then we'll
go back to prison food because everybody
is still very interested looking at me
all louis ck's christian that would bob
woman yes you know i love you i know was
a tough thanksgiving i got your [ __ ]
sucked at kevin k robbie danger
whatever Alex honey much lon Rosenthal I
love you Jay Biggs
over in Pittsburgh and sherry row back
don't forget about me next Sunday at the
Novo downtown on our way with my man we
love war how did that come together
don't worry what's with the question is
all of a sudden you woke variety
servitor in San Diego where we will walk
with Julian York with Joey and then
Tuesday 12 5 we're again at the
observatory in the Santa Ana
tickets are going fast they're [ __ ]
cheap $20 it's a [ __ ] came and I don't
get that [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] King they'll
be free stay if you like finger and
[ __ ] this would be your type of
90 I'm saying just walk around with a
good like a good Jew with Vaseline on
one finger that's all you need two hands
and two fingers of Vaseline okay what
figure did you put it on me I'm a slimy
[ __ ] tribal on four fingers yeah
actually you can't
how did you catch him with the hoof the
back of the pinky
you know Joey waiting work tell me what
how did it come together you're doing
shows of wheeler I met him twice yeah
and we spoke about it and he said he was
doing some bigger venues and he wanted
to use a comic what I think I'm gonna
try that's awesome man that's [ __ ]
awesome white look big fan I'm uh it's
time for comments to start opening up
for bands and get yeah it's time for
to start opening up for you I forward
you know Dean Delray and put some
together this year a bus tour yeah with
some band and they realized they
couldn't fit the two continents on a bus
which Jesus Christ how all the way down
yeah yeah you're the adult you want to
be in a bus fart and your feet you say
how will be valid not only will the bus
tour like I want to be raped you don't
say that it's how only gonna bother we
have all the boys problem I'm gonna
adopt I want a hotel room listen house
in the back of the plane but I don't
want no bus no but I know I can't sleep
with so many drivers really yeah I just
can't do unless I'm driving I'm like I
don't listen I'm not gonna sit there
next to you I know how Isis one minute
I'm dreaming about getting my dick
sucked the next but I'm going off a
cliff because the [ __ ] joint is
burning are you sure responsible drivers
Joey who the first companies yeah yeah
yeah I see it all the time like the
little [ __ ] chenkin had died the
back of the bus to let them back there
from heat exposure a little [ __ ]
this little [ __ ] [ __ ] giddy yeah
every [ __ ] another week there's
something with a bus driving at night
texting Chinese kid [ __ ] diner heat
exposures now back this weekend should
be Pepsi in it don't you yeah I must
have messed that one man so what's the
future like the Tom Segura what do you
want brother I mean right now you got
the world by the balls
you doing theatres you're doing well in
the theaters I mean you're a great guy
deserve
you've got you're a great writer you
know thanks man I don't know dude I want
to keep doing it and I want to I'm
trying to develop a show honestly so
hoping that that pans out to something
and yeah man I'm trying to make us movie
I'm trying to a couple things you guys
are the crazy things about TV shows are
right now listen you think about your
life and you know you know what I'd like
to show on that fact they're gonna go
there every day and break my balls yeah
the reason why you get into comedies but
you don't want to jump yeah
once a comedian feels like he has a job
that's what we don't respond well not in
a problem stop just can never feel like
a job if we wanted a job we would have
quit this Oh long time ago I'm checking
the nine-to-five right that's the
problem for me I never want it to feel
like a job you still to take it
seriously
I want it to feel like when I go to
somewhere to do a free set and when I go
somewhere I'm Friday and get paid I want
the same feeling right I wasn't getting
it lately I just want to get on stage
and get the [ __ ] off that's it lately
yeah I want to fall in love with it do
you think time away I'll do that time
men's Abril insane time away going on
the set and working and I'm working with
a few [ __ ] directors and yeah through
it some dumb [ __ ] from time to time
makes you realize how good you got a
stand-up all and at the same time you're
writing you're writing from a different
perspective is from writing with a gun
to your head pushing jokes that really
don't work but they have to work because
right you're on the road getting $25 a
ticket yeah do you follow me yeah I go
to flappers Monday through Thursday I
called Bob come on Lionel is it Monday
through Thursday from closing the
shelter now I'm gonna charge you nuts
I'm not gonna tweet it I'm not gonna do
that
that's your job yeah but I'll be there
every night they're gonna close this
show that's my [ __ ] 90 days of
training
I'm Friday and Saturday I'll take it to
the battleground to take it to the
commies don't follow run wife and see
what you think now
yeah see you double jokey pull works
behind run white that's the way to do it
yeah but for you the two audiences with
who chokes in Omaha and then trying to
go back the next year I don't I just
don't want to do it right I try to spray
some other v8 team months that's the get
schedule they don't day to hear it again
and they've been hearing it now and I
want to change my whole demeanor I've
changed
do you with me yeah I've changed you
know that the the Jew jokes who used to
be funny
these somebody's monkey used to be funny
then these are the this is how Madonna
changes everybody changes yeah so you
feel that transition yeah and I'm not
talking about it I don't even know what
the [ __ ] is right I don't even know
you feel like that's all the matters I'm
feeling that I want to raise a daughter
yeah so she doesn't run into Harvey
Weinstein yeah
that's your main goal you know you with
your son you have goals for your son I
prefer Vienna I mean there's so many
things you want you know do I want to go
up there do people want to hear my
political views with a [ __ ] but I'm a
fat [ __ ] felon yeah and my political
views are like [ __ ] al franken taking
a picture grabbing your tits it sucks
inside yeah yeah [ __ ] there was four
out Frank in that dirty [ __ ] uh-huh
whoa
he's what captain BOTS he's got busted a
lot of [ __ ] I said bro you know
America's man all of a sudden has been
going you don't think Abe Lincoln got
his dick sucked yeah for sure if they
all got been dick suck you know they
just found out have these [ __ ]
presence had [ __ ] goombazz that were
black and then we'll have a threesome
slaves as [ __ ] as long as after its
death yeah where do you see this job CNN
huh you know I've seen it no I'm too
busy reading Yelp reports on some Thai
restaurant you want to go to the Century
City me I'm looking [ __ ] up look at his
eyes look at his eyes there's nothing
left
whoa so the CD comes out the new special
Netflix comes out January 12th yes and
it's called disgraceful okay and what
does the tour
start to support see the [ __ ] there's
no tour plan right now man
I plan on being home for a while like
this thing's coming out and I'm gonna be
home for a while you know people
understand that after you shoot a
special you put so much effort and
thought into it you physically
emotionally work out but because of your
situation you know you know what I'll go
out the following weeks after yeah and
that's just a waste of time that's what
I did and that was always the time to
cancel many days after that and you
watch movies for 90 days
yeah right the great poem will be told
me something once I said told what do
you do when you're stuck writing he goes
don't pick up the pen and go get
entertained I'll really go get
entertained and sometimes bro you know
what you go to the comedy store and
you'll watch the greats Marin burr
Sebastian yeah I have a good time and yo
giggle but sometimes you walk into a
coffee shop and you see a beginner and
you see their eyes
can you see the eyes that you used to
have yeah you know Myron burr
Sebastian Brogan the lives of that
killers yeah they have a certain look in
their eyes but it's not have you ever
done Toby's thing of one day like yes
yeah when those guys going oh yes within
their eyes
oh yeah that's different you mean you
look at their eyes you drive home going
a bit more boy let's go like that yeah
when doing five minutes in the belly
room and being light let the world like
it this did work out tonight I might go
home to shoot myself yeah you don't like
and you look at those comic sighs those
guys inspire the [ __ ] out of it yeah I
love it man
I like seeing young comics I really do I
love it I like I don't actually love a
lot of those I don't want to sound what
people come up to me and go Joey come
here yeah come look at this next comic
he's really hot my dick just went soft
right can we probably get super high
once in the back I'll get a water and I
just want to see ten guys do six minutes
appear and laughs my [ __ ] ass off
because I know where they're going
I know where they're at yeah I know what
they're not thinking about that they
haven't even thought about and they're
funny it inspires you though right
that's why you like it I love it I'm
gonna start going back for I have to
yeah because this [ __ ] is ruined
it's wrong with us if it's you're right
we take this I'm proud you said that
tonight thank you for reaffirming my
beliefs on the Sally out Friday and
Saturday yeah for me too better have a
better set I also do a little work out
definitely and I've done I don't leave
there either I did it's very happy with
the elliptical on this tour probably 98%
of the shows there was a workout before
the show I have to do it now to feel
normal because I like the five to five
o'clock 35 minutes on the elliptical 25
lifts and some weights maybe 10 on
stretching you go upstairs you call room
service
you wash your [ __ ] yep you come out of
the shower you dressed as a knock on the
door you [ __ ] whatever you wait
fifteen twenty minutes it's time to go
that's a perfect [ __ ] knife of it
yeah you gonna sit there there's an
opening act
you still got now before you go up the
food digest you go up on stage there is
tip-top Magoo it's the bestest blood
rather for you like how to do it you
have a little Hannibal yeah and if
people out there if you do stand-up you
haven't tried the pre-show workout start
easy man
do like like do a casual 30-minute walk
on a [ __ ] treadmill but yes I know a
room yeah get out of your room
it'll make you all long TV exercising in
your room no I want you to get out of
your room because you go in your room
too much in a room start creeping up on
you yeah if you wanna walk go for a walk
around the neighborhood put a hooded
sweatshirt on or go downstairs stylist
Emma I never did it
yeah and [ __ ] Rogen used to do a used
to drive me crazy
with what he would call me in hotels
what what is going on - Jimmy really
join me and I'm like I just took a coked
a lot out of my nose from last night I'm
chewing on it haha I don't [ __ ] love
his hell and you want to know if I want
to meet you in the gym not in a million
years he would always do something yeah
I was going on stairs towards the
anything on you leave I'm like I was
gonna spec and his shirt would always be
dreadful yeah and he would go up then do
a [ __ ] great show and now Thursday
night I thought I don't have time to go
and yeah okay but Friday that elliptical
do you know every place has dumbbells
yeah so you do the benching you do the
incline you took a bent over rows you do
the shrug that you do the curls you do
try some extensions you do sit-ups
push-ups you do the elliptical you
listen to the side wonderfully with Mac
rumors you get your whole thing it's a
pleasure to see you you too brother
it's a pleasure to come on we did not
discuss parts which is always successful
what I'm saving for your show your mom's
house tomorrow
for the shoe you had last week can't
wait don't tell me he's like yeah how
you feeling my brother you [ __ ] up you
went to Vegas you lost money you came
back like a mobile yeah I'm don't
blackjack and no I think I've done poker
- poker with both poker stunk
I'm gonna have to go on someone else
then maybe you're a better room they
took it so seriously like I'm he's
having fun of blackjack and like no one
will talk to the table poker oh really
so it's million for keeps
vomit you want to do jokes no [ __ ]
watch comedians I said your problem is
you want there ha ha ha and they trick
you with them eventful [ __ ] toughness
and your folder pressure which is no
problem what's the buy-in there 65 65 it
was just trying it out yeah it's fun but
I like pie gal and I've been on the
Celtics in once those I'm happy you went
to Vegas and have a good time thank you
you needed to get some [ __ ] off your
[ __ ] chest to drive help you look
better
Alex thanks money was great at your
house brother where'd you go I have we
hosted this year we had friends over we
have family again I'm gonna call your
dad now where did where was yours at the
house yeah the same thing I called you
me back you you're [ __ ] that the Lucy
cave look-alike contest oh I thought I'm
the Leeside look-alike is no you get
handsomer ya know so what do you view
because they are you look the no sugar
keto I tried to yeah that's that's what
the endless you tried that no I have it
that's what I have to do yeah yeah cut
the sugar man change everything
nothing no I'm not sure the guy you know
well I don't give a [ __ ] yeah I just
that's the Teva
[ __ ] - my iced tea yeah they should just
a cancer-free one right yeah yeah yeah
yeah
tastes like dick yeah me live longer
yeah the mice just go cross-eyed that's
yeah let's go cross that that means
somewhere
yeah no big deal no big deal and that's
it my brother you have any tour dates
coming up well I got yeah yeah I got
Phoenix okay December 7th 8th and 9th
all right stand up live and then I'm
doing Hawaii I'm doing this place in
Maui on the 14th and the Hawaii theatre
and Honolulu on the 16th
say hello to BJ Penn like I said always
a pleasure it's great that you're
enjoying fatherhood it's awesome yeah
thanks for having me man and she's all
great mom no I had a happy to kick off
[ __ ] this is the week after
Thanksgiving we can't [ __ ] around no
more
Lisa a hat I love your [ __ ] we'll
be back Wednesday whoo don't worry about
don't ask no [ __ ] questions all right
let me just drop it on yet nice and
easily again like I told you the
beginning of the show holiday season is
coming it started this week with the
[ __ ] pumpkin pie and the whipped
cream and you have a little extra
whipped cream we all did and I'm gonna
throw you in jail for that but like I
said if you're trying to eat better the
holidays or a minefield between the
chocolates the cookies the candy canes
it's no fun being left out of
deliciousness let naturebox help me with
snacks that you love and are seriously
delicious and better for you the
holidays are not always a holiday you
got stuff to do people to shop for and
cheer the spread you need to keep your
body fueled for all the festivities but
a lot of the holiday treats are just
junk you and I both know that yeah
they're delicious but healthy no but
throughout the day you know how many
calories you eat stopping at this guy's
house this guy's house let nature about
help with snacks or the better for you
delicious nature box has over 100
delicious snacks or all snacks are made
with high quality simple ingredients
this means no artificial colors flavors
or sweetness it's easy just go to
naturebox.com/tyler snacks and naturebox
will deliver them listen to me right to
your door Lou snacks are had in every
month
inspired by food trends professional
chefs and customers
back all right I told you last week they
sent me the beautiful jerky they also
have these crackers these thought these
see soft cassava chips that'll make your
head spin you understand me
the Sorachi roasted cashews I can't the
whole wheat fig come on guys I'm going
he that Jovi and there's no risk if you
don't like the snack naturebox will
replace it for free and like I told you
the church your family right now
naturebox is offering all you savages
you know I love you listen 5050 50
percent off right now off your first
daughter if you go to naturebox calm
this is what you want in your house for
the holidays right now that do listen I
can go on for hours about the snacks
it'll kill you we'll be in for two years
that's nature banks calm so we for 50%
off your first order again
naturebox.com/tyler 50% off your order
nature box this is the healthy way to go
listen then how long days are gonna kill
you this is the way to go again
naturebox.com/tyler we what goes up must
come down
what you put down your throat comes out
that muffler yep so I'm feeding you but
at the same time I'm keeping that Oh
god's clean because when you're riding
your Christmas list to Santa this year
tell that the little son of a [ __ ]
that's number one
he owes your money and number two you
want the Christmas some clean butt
cheeks all year you know you live around
with that swamp [ __ ] ass you ever get
a [ __ ] the chicks eyebrows go on fine
and say drinking pop pop rock you know
why her eyebrows looking at you weird
because she could tolerate sucking a
dick but she knows if she opens up on
your legs it's gonna be like [ __ ]
tear gas
I said [ __ ] Batman release on [ __ ] is
Adreno on it anyway you don't need to
live like that and you got that excess
pine cones coming from your [ __ ]
because paying dingleberries as if they
used to call him and that fudgy [ __ ]
pudding smudge all over yonder where's
unholy night let me tell you something
you neither tushy but de you like Joey
what's a bad day let me figure it out
for you right it's a portable device
then you attach right to your toilet
takes you 10 minutes we don't wanna take
it attach it let me tell you something
you're attached it you take a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] you talkin turn the water
on the pressure takes your ass all the
different levels you understand me but
for some people it might change your
life you just sit there all day you've
got nothing to do but you know clean yes
better than the [ __ ] toilet paper in
the van you're like me agree you know oh
my god I have the cold one and I start
every day with an L oh it's amazing
in the morning then you sit and you peel
while your [ __ ] gets a cold water
yeah that's the best yeah you wanta have
to take a shower as long as your
[ __ ] fresh words from cold water
Yeah right before the shower and let me
tell you some of the [ __ ] get in the
cold water or vitalizes your nerves yeah
it gets everything moving would treat
the oatmeal and it hello there right now
but one of my nutritionist what I'm
telling you is this hello Lucy doctor is
the way to go why cause you get a 60 day
money-back guarantee which I've been
using mine for two years and I'm 300
[ __ ] pounds and if I haven't broke it
you ain't gonna break [ __ ] yours so
clean your ass better and you use clean
water to spray your but providing ish
your shower fresh feeling after every
[ __ ] disgusting [ __ ] you think
there's no more skid marks no more sugar
burn fairies and then our dear ass crack
just an [ __ ]
cleaner than white Christmas you
understand me I love mine I'm telling
you this is the way to do it go Tudor
she go - hello - she calm and use code
church for 10% off your and they start
at $69 surely Santa could afford that
stop wiping your [ __ ] nasty [ __ ]
with that disgusting cheap toilet paper
that breaks through and then you got
[ __ ] on your fingernails too New Year's
Day stop wasting a good time go - hello
- she calm use code Church CH you are CH
and get 10% off your order
as usual I love you guys with all my
heart don't forget next Sunday no vote
with wheeler Monday San Diego with the
observatory and Tuesday at the Asura
Torre in Santa Ana and I want to thank
one of the best guys in comedy and Itay
this in the bottom of my heart
Tom Segura go - Tom Segura what.com and
check out his dates and give them the
love he deserves Lisa at Happy Hanukkah
thank you I'm going to the holy month
absolutely I want you to reserve it no
more [ __ ] around
only kosher meat don't want Thai food
and [ __ ] you know filthy [ __ ] say like
taffy you're gonna [ __ ] yourself anyway
you're the best man
thanks for having me I love you guys
with all my heart have a great week and
we'll see you Wednesday
stay black bye